All right. What's up, YouTube? As
always, welcome to another live stream,
or in the words of my guest, um, common
phrase, he likes to say, post tenner lux
after darkness light. Uh, so this stream
was actually supposed to happen last
week. So, in light of that, I will still
say happy belated ascension day. Uh, and
how fitting that this specific stream
was originally slated to land on that
specific day, the day that the Christian
church celebrates and remembers the
ascension of our Lord into heaven. But I
want to start tonight with a question
for the audience.
Have you ever heard or been told by a
proponent of Adventist theology, pastor,
lay member, whoever, that if you reject
the investigative judgment, you must not
think that Jesus is a high priest or
that the investigative judgment explains
why Jesus hasn't returned yet. These are
pretty common claims and tactics that
are used by SDA apologists to try and
prop up this idea of their novel
doctrine around the heavenly sanctuary
in the investigative judgment. So,
tonight we're going to be getting into
this pillar doctrine of the Adventist
Church as well as the high priestly role
of Jesus Christ. And we're going to talk
about what that looks like biblically.
Um what Christians have understood long
before the birth of the Seventh Day
Adventist movement. Um followed by
examining this investigative judgment in
light of that.
But to set the framework, we're going to
do something a little bit differently.
Um, this stream,
I want to actually play a short clip of
Clifford Goldstein. For those who don't
know, Cliff Goldstein is the editor of
the Seventh Day Adventist Sabbath School
Quarterly, uh, of 24 years, I think. Uh,
and I want you to notice what he
recognizes and what he claims and
admits. So, I'm going to play a short
clip here and then we will be back as
per usual.
But then it hits me. It hits me that the
only thing I didn't understand from the
Bible alone, the very thing that was
coming under sustained attack
was the 2300 day 2300 year prophecy of
Daniel 8:14.
I thought, well, isn't that sweet? you
know, because it was we were being
attacked from within on that by all
sorts of people,
throwing up all sorts of arguments, and
I was green. I I didn't I knew nothing.
And I have to admit, I was thrown
when that when I got hit with that.
Now, I I like to tell people I don't
really consider myself
a particularly deep thinker,
but I'm a logical thinker. I think
logically. I think I got it from my dad
who was a mathematician.
And I think logically and it hit me that
if 1844 is wrong,
if this isn't true, then our church was
founded on a lie. It's as simple as
that. It was, and I'm going to touch on
this a little more tomorrow. So I
realize if our church arose from the the
aftermath the wreckage you want of the
Millerite movement based on our
reinterpretation of the 2300 days and I
realized I said I'm sorry if that is
wrong then the entire justification the
entire prophetic foundation of our
church was wrong.
So there you heard.
What does he admit? Folks, I've said
this on the channel before.
People said, "No, no, that's not the
case."
He admits it. If this teaching is wrong,
then you admit that the Adventist church
is built on a lie.
You concede that Ellen White was a false
prophet because she claimed to be shown
this teaching to be true in vision from
God. and the whole house of cards
collapses.
The people at the top of this
organization are not alikart style
adventists. They understand the
centrality of this. You cannot
consistently be a 7th day Adventist and
reject this teaching. So I've said it
before and I'll keep saying it. All
Adventist roads lead back to 1844. So
remember this as we discuss tonight.
Whether you are presently an Adventist,
a former Adventist, never been an
Adventist, tonight's stream is going to
bless you. Um, and it's of absolute
importance that Christians properly
understand, especially former
Adventists, um, the high priestly role
of Jesus, um, his rulership as a king,
his perfect intercession for his people.
And thankfully, our guest tonight is
extremely qualified to help out with
this. So, with me to discuss is Pastor
Anthony Rogers. He received an AA in
Christian thought from Christ College in
Lynchburg, Virginia, and a bachelor's of
divinity or bachelor, I think it is,
singular of divinity from Greenville
Presbyterian Theological Seminary in
Greenville, South Carolina. He has a
targeted focus and interest in defending
the truth of Christianity against Islam
as well as other ideologies, religions,
and cults, uh, which started back in
1993 when he became a believer. In
addition to various journal entries,
he's been a longtime contributor to
answering Islam.org, orans answering
Muslims.com and has done a number of
videos with YouTuber David Wood and has
a YouTube channel of his own. But before
I bring him in, the way it will work
tonight is I'm actually going to play
devil's advocate to a degree from the
Seventh Day Adventist perspective. I
want to work through some of the common
claims made by uh the SDA church
regarding this teaching obviously um and
then let Anthony respond from the
Christian position and do um a decent
amount of teaching in doing so. Um as
always at the end, we'll open the floor
to audience Q&A. So, have your questions
ready, but I will prompt you when to
send those through. Folks, if you send
your question through right now, it's
going to get lost in the comments. So,
hold that and I will prompt you. But
with that said, Anthony, thank you so
much for being here.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah. Um, I was pleasantly surprised
when I found out that you were uh good
friends with one of my ruling elders. I
was actually very very shocked um when I
asked Anthony to come on the show. Um, I
always have a little bit of a write up
that I send people to let them know I'm
not just uh some rogue person that's
just kind of doing whatever. Um, I'm a
part of a church and I typically say
what my church is. Um, and his response
was super shocking because I didn't
expect him to respond with the name of
one of my elders, specifically my ruling
elder. Um, so I was really kind of taken
back by that, but that was cool. So, uh,
yeah, thanks for being here. But let's
get right into this. So, I want you to
explain here at the beginning um what is
the high priestly role of Jesus and what
does that look like? I want to bring up
before you give your answer, I actually
want to bring up um the shorter
catechism.
So, question 25 in the the Westminster
Shorter Catechism, it says, "How does
Christ execute the office of a priest?"
Christ executes the office of a priest
in his once offering up of himself a
sacrifice to satisfy divine justice and
reconcile us to God and in making
continual intercession for us. So can
you expound upon what is being gotten at
here? How does Christ function as a high
priest?
Yeah, so the shorter catechism, I didn't
know you were going to quote that, but
uh it's perfect summary of what it means
to be a priest, what it means for Christ
to be our high priest. And essentially
it has two components. First to offer up
himself to God as an atoning sacrifice
for sin which he did on the cross and
then secondly to intercede for his
bloodbought people at the right hand of
his father on the basis of his completed
sacrifice. Now one passage among a
myriad number of passages that speak to
both of these is Hebrews 7. In Hebrews
7:26, it says, "For it was fitting for
us to have such a high priest." Note, it
doesn't have to always say high priest
for it to be talking about Christ's
office of high priest or his high
priestly functions. But here it
explicitly mentions him as high priest.
It says, "It was fitting for such for us
to have such a high priest, holy,
innocent, undefiled, separated from
sinners, and exalted above the heavens,
who does not need daily, like those high
priests, to offer up sacrifices first
for his own sins and then for the sins
of this of the people, because this he
did once for all when he offered up
himself." So, Hebrews 7:26 says that
Jesus as our high priest offered himself
up to God as a sacrifice. But then just
immediately before that in verse 25 of
chapter 7 it uh drawing upon the
implications of Christ's resurrection
namely that he's alive right he
continues then uh in this priestly
capacity uh it says therefore he is also
able to save forever those who draw near
to God through him since he always lives
to make intercession for them. So as the
shorter catechism says these two things
in are involved in Christ's high
priestly work namely to be a sacrifice
for our sin and to intercede for us and
the former preceded the latter and is
the foundation for the latter which is
ongoing. The former isn't the latter is
this an act where Jesus is still dealing
with sin.
Uh not sure. Well, so I I should say so
I've had limited interaction with
Adventists and you may at times have to
explain to me more exactly what their
position is, but when you say deal with
sin, that's ambiguous to me. Uh, in one
sense, uh, certainly he's dealing with
sin. Psalm 110 says that he's putting
all enemies beneath his feet.
Yeah,
that's not, I think, what you likely
have in mind. I I have some modest
knowledge of Adventism. Uh and so uh I
don't think it, you know, in any
relevant sense to the Adventists
distinctive claims. No, he he has atoned
for sin. Uh atonement has been made and
now he's bringing people into subjection
to himself either willingly that is as
his people by his spirit or uh
unwillingly overtoppling them and uh
conquering them and so forth.
Yeah. So you answered my question there
indirectly and may not know it and maybe
I should have held that off. But now
what we're going to do, so it's very
simple like you like you said. This is
why I wanted to make a little slide here
for the shorter catechism because it's
very succinct. It's to the point and
it's exactly what scripture says in
regards to the high priestly work of
Christ. So now I'm going to steal man,
the investigative judgment. I compiled
this from Ellen White's Christ in his
sanctuary. I'm going to read through.
I've read this before on the channel, so
sorry folks who have heard this before,
but some of you, I'm sure, have not. So,
we're going to lay out what this is,
think about what Anthony just said, and
then we'll get into some questions
regarding specifically what's said here.
And Anthony, I'll uh explain some of
these things to you as well, the the
definitions or scaling the language
barrier. But it says, "There is a
sanctuary in heaven identical to that of
the earthly." By identical, we mean or
they mean a scale model. The one in
heaven's obviously a lot bigger and
grander than that what that what was on
earth but that was a scale model. In
Jesus entered the most holy place of
this sanctuary to begin the
investigative judgment. Prior to this he
only entered into the holy place of that
sanctuary to do a work of intercession
analogous to that of the Levitical
ironic priesthood like in Leviticus 16.
The investigative judgment is the final
phase of Christ's atoning ministry prior
to the second advent. This is to say the
atonement was not completed at the cross
but continues in heaven until the work
of investigation is finalized.
In this judgment, the record books of
sin are opened and all the lives of uh
of all who have professed faith come up
in review before God. It is a judgment
only for professed believers. The wicked
in their theology will be judged during
the 10,000-year millennium reign. And
let me actually move this little
brandark out of the way so that we can
see. Beginning with the cases of the
dead spanning back to Adam and Eve,
Jesus is reviewing the life records of
every person who's professed faith in
God. Every name is mentioned and every
case is closely examined. When he
finishes with one generation, he moves
to the next. Once the cases of the dead
are complete, he will move to the cases
of the living. None know when this
change will happen.
Anyone who has sins remaining upon the
books of record, whether unconfessed or
forgotten, will have their names blotted
out of the book of life. Every sin must
be confessed to be blotted out. The
standard that all people are judged up
against is the Ten Commandments and
their perfect obedience to them,
especially the seventh day Sabbath of
the 4th. Some names will be accepted,
others will be rejected. When every
person has come up in review, only then
will Jesus plead his blood before the
father on behalf of those who are found
worthy followed by bl Yeah. followed by
blotting out their sins from the record
books. Then not knowing whether this
work has been completed, those who are
found worthy, still in their current
human state, will have to stand in the
sight of Almighty God without an
intercessor. This is prior to the second
advent. Jesus will then take the sins of
God's people and transfer them to Satan,
who they believe is represented by the
Leviticus 16 Day of Atonement scapegoat.
Satan will bear the ultimate
responsibility for all the sins he's
caused the righteous to commit,
suffering for them in the lake of fire
to eventually be blotted from existence,
making Satan the final sin bearer. This
then completes the atonement and
vindicates the character of God before
all watching intelligences and everyone
will see the immutability of the law of
God and his righteous character.
So that is it in a nutshell. This book
Christ in a sanctuary is a what's called
a compilation book. It is where her
estate has essentially compiled her
statements from all these different
books on this specific topic and
compiled it down to specifically the the
doctrine of the sanctuary and the
investigative judgment. So, we're going
to tackle some of this. Now, I know that
there was a lot there and I'm sure
you're thinking if you've never seen
this before, holy smokes. So,
let's get into tearing this apart some.
according to scripture.
Was atonement completed at the cross or
is it continuing in heaven? And Jesus
went to heaven to begin the next phase
of atoning ministry,
right? Well, yeah, you already know
where I'm going to go with this. I I
think it was already anticipated in
answer to the first question, namely
that Christ made atonement and now on
the basis of that, he's interceding for
us. He's pleading for his people uh
before his father. I mentioned the book
of Hebrews and really I think this is
the place to go. Not exclusively by any
stretch, but uh it's just so rich here
and obviously has Christ's priestly work
as its focus. I imagine that Adventists
for that reason probably have taken a
special interest in the book. I I don't
know that from experience and reading
their writings, but it just it occurs to
me that since they've got this peculiar
view of the sanctuary and and judgment
and all this sort of thing, that would
have to be a book where they're
occupying their time and interest. But
you think about the book of Hebrews.
Here's something great about the book of
Hebrews. The whole book is about the
superiority of Christ and his work over
against that of what came before. So
doesn't matter what you talk about
whether it's the role of prophets in
revealing God and the way of redemption
or angels and and what they do in the
economy of redemption, what role they
have. Uh you name it. The book of
Hebrews indicates that Christ and his
work is superior to all of that. And so
right out of the shootute in the book of
Hebrews, Hebrews chapter 1, this is the
prologue to the book. So the author says
several things and then he gives a
litany of Old Testament citations. But
what he says in those prefaratory words
is among other things that Christ after
he provided purification for sins sat
down at the right hand of the majesty on
high. Now, before going to that, and I I
think you're already aware of where I'm
going with this, but right before that,
I just want to note this finality idea
that the author of Hebrews is pushing.
He says that in the past, God spoke to
our fathers through the prophets at
various various times and in many ways.
And the idea that the author is
communicating is something of the uh
lack of completeness. God is revealing
himself to be sure and revealing
important things but this is partial
it's incomplete and then this is
contrasted with what's brought in Christ
in contrast to this partial revelation
in the past at various time in many ways
it says in these last days he has spoken
and the grammar there indicates the
finality of this the word that has been
brought in Christ is a final word and
it's similar to the point that Jesus
makes In Mark 12, remember Jesus gives
this parable
where he says that a vineyard was rented
out. You know, there's a a vineyard
owner. He rents out this vineyard and
the tenants are expected to give
something of the proceeds to the the
owner of the vineyard and he sends
servants to them, but they don't
properly receive the servants. They
mistreat them and so he sends more and
they do the same and they even kill some
of them. And then finally it says last
of all he sent his son. In other words,
in these last days he has spoken to us
through his son. So the son is the final
climactic revelation of God which by the
way is also pointed out in the book of
Daniel, right? I I know we'll eventually
probably go there, but uh in the book of
Daniel, it talks about him bringing uh
all these things to completion. All that
redemptive history has been moving
towards. And so the point being though
in Hebrews that you have this note of
finality with the son and it's the same
point that's being made with respect to
his atoning work after he provided
purification for sins. The author of
Hebrews says he sat down at the right
hand of the majesty in heaven. Now I
mentioned in Hebrews 1, this is the
preface, the prologue and then he gives
a litany of citations. And really these
citations, all of this is setting you up
for what he's going to unpack in the
rest of the book.
It's like he's giving you his sermon
text, but he hasn't limited himself to
one. He's he's given you several. And
then he's going to in one way or another
in the exposition of the book, he's
going to somehow tie in these verses.
Well, one of the texts that he cites is
Psalm 110 towards the end of the
prologue. And what does Psalm 110 say?
The Lord said to my Lord, "Sit at my
right hand until I make your enemies
your foottool." Now, what is Psalm 110
about? And uh what is its relevance to
the book of Hebrews? Well, you already
should note the the language there. He
said that after he provided purification
for sins, he sat down. He Psalm 110
says, "The Lord said to my Lord, sit at
my right hand." It's the same act of
sitting that's in view here. And and I I
didn't say, but I'm I'm kind of assuming
people understand that when it speaks of
him sitting, the idea is that he's
completed his work. This is now him
consequent upon having done the work of
atonement now sitting. He's at rest, if
you will. Uh and and so this is what the
author is going to go on and unpack. And
so let me just run over a handful of
passages from the book, and you can see
this. Uh so for example in 7:26 which I
already quoted uh it says that he
offered up himself once for all. There
you have the note of finality. In 9:12
it says he entered the holy place once
for all having obtained eternal
redemption. And then several verses
later in the same uh chapter it speaks
of Christ having been offered once to
bear the sins of many and says he did it
so so as to put away sin by the
sacrifice of himself. And so over and
over again, it notes the finality of his
atoning work. And then to cap it all off
in Hebrews 10, as if now to come full
circle to what he opened up with in
Hebrews 1, it says in Hebrews 10, every
priest stands daily ministering and
offering time after time the same
sacrifices. Again, note the idea of
repetition, incompleteness, and so
forth. It says, "Every priest stands
daily ministering and offering time
after time. the same sacrifices which
can never take away sins. But he having
offered one sacrifice for sins for all
time sat down at the right hand of God.
So notice the sitting is subsequent to
the having offered himself as a
sacrifice for sin having made atonement.
And then it says waiting from that time
onward until his enemies be made a
foottool for his feet referring back to
Psalm 110. And we shouldn't miss, by the
way, the the effects of this in Hebrews
10. Uh we're told that he died to
accomplish atonement and that his work
was completed. He sat down. And then it
speaks of the benefits that acrew to us
from this. In in verse 14, it says, "For
by one offering he has perfected for all
time those who are sanctified." And so
the picture, note the whole picture
here, the whole book is about the
finality of what Christ accomplishes
because of the superiority of his
person. Of course, what he does
completes whatever was left incomplete
from the Old Testament, whether it's
prophecy, uh, kingship, everything is
summed up in him. And he having made
atonement then sits down. His work is
finished. And those for whom that
sacrifice was offered have been made
perfect. The author of Hebrews says,
"Yeah, there's just like
we're going to get into a lot of this
tonight, which I'm glad, but there's
just so many things there that um are
just so opposite of this system." Um,
and so you mentioned earlier how they
must love the book of Hebrews. And um,
they love proof texting. They're big
proof textters. So they love Hebrews
4:9, for example. Therefore, there
remains a Sabbath rest for the people of
God to try and then weasel in their
teaching on that. Um, so they're
typically big on proof text. Um, but
they're not big on necessarily walking
through the text kind of like you've
been showing an overview here. And when
you do that, like you've pointed out,
um, there's something very drastically
different here. You've mentioned the
word a couple times and I want you to
define it just because this is a key
component here. What do we mean when we
say atonement? You've said that Christ
completed the atonement. Um it was
finished. These types of things because
in Adventist vernacular they have an
initial and final atonement. So the
initial atonement was what Jesus did at
the cross. But the final atonement will
come after through this work of
investigation. there's actually a a
three a tripartide uh judgment and the
investigative pre-advent judgment is
just the first phase of this judgment
and so for them this whole long process
is atonement that includes um the
reconciliation of all things they'll say
well there's still sin in the world so
obviously atonement's still going on
Jesus is still dealing with sin so
that's kind of what I was getting at
earlier so what do we mean when we say
the word atonement
yeah so it's interesting you say that.
So it the word salvation for just to use
this for a moment uh actually has a
past, present and future tense and it's
used in all those ways in the New
Testament. And this points to the fact
that there are certain uh things
related to what Christ has done that uh
do have or involve past, present and
future things. We would say for example
that uh we were saved, right? Christ has
died for us. Uh our salvation has been
accomplished and we are objectively
uh beneficiaries now of that. We're
justified before God. We have been
justified, Paul says in Romans. Uh but
then scripture also envisions us being
sanctified. That's something that's
ongoing. So scripture can also speak of
believers being saved. Christ doesn't
just deliver us from our guilt and
corruption, blot out our sin, its debt
and so forth. Uh he also delivers us
from our inborn corruption and uh
inclination to sin and that sort of
thing. So that can be spoken of in the
present tense and as something ongoing.
And then scripture speaks of a final
thing that happens namely glorification
when God raises us up and uh we are as
the author of Hebrews puts it the
spirits of just men made perfect. Right?
But then also our bodies are are
glorified. So you have this sort of
thing. The reason I mention this is
because you'd sort of expect then to see
if atonement is what they're saying it
is. You'd expect to see it being used in
this way. Past, present, future tense,
right? I I don't even know what they
might if they've ever tried to to point
to this language. I'm sure there's
there's stuff in the Bible they try to
point to to prove this concept, but just
initially thinking of I I can't even
think of anything where it would justify
this this language. But anyway, so so
now coming more directly to your
question. Atonement speaks to the work
of Christ giving his life as a
substitute for his people and enduring
the penalty that was was due to them.
And when scripture elucidates this, it
speaks of his death as propitiatory.
So that's a fancy word, not used as much
now, but it's used in Romans 3, 1 John
2, 1 John 4, uh, to talk about Christ
plating the wrath of God or, uh,
satisfying the wrath of God, thereby
turning it away from us. So propitiation
or expeation, those two really go
together, uh, is is what was being
accomplished when Christ gave himself on
the cross for his people. And then
redemption refers to Christ uh
purchasing us uh or paying the debt that
was uh otherwise due by us to the
justice of God. This is spoken of in
Mark 10:45 for example when it says uh
the son of man did not come to be served
but to serve and to give his life as a
ransom for many or again Romans 3 speaks
of the redemption that's in Christ
Jesus. And then it also speaks of
reconciliation. It it speaks of us being
reconciled to God. But more
fundamentally, this is something that
happens because God has been reconciled
to us through the death of Christ. But
all of this is related to what Christ
did on the cross, not to something
future. Christ has given himself as a
substitute for our sins. He has endured
the curse that's due to us. Galatians 3.
All of this is clearly put in the
rearview mirror. It's not something
scripture portrays as a yet future
uh reality.
That's good. Um so we've defined now or
laid out what we mean by atonement. Um
what we mean by um that being complete
um as well as um the high priestly role
that's involved with that. So with that,
let's transition now into addressing
some of these things that were said in
the the steel man. We'll kind of work
through the order. So the first one
being at his ascension, did Jesus enter
into a physical building in heaven where
he only went into the holy place of that
building that was essentially the true
tabernacle that the earthly tabernacle
was modeled after? Or
is something else being said by the
text? because this is a key component
for them and this gets into their
physicalist worldview that all that's
really real is that which is organic and
tangible physical and so they believe
that when Jesus at his ascension he went
into this physical building in heaven
and entered into the holy place and for
1811 years he was only doing the the
outer apartment ministerial work until
1844 when he transitioned into the most
holy place of that apartment. What are
your thoughts on that?
Yeah, I mean we gota we no doubt have to
get into the stuff that they believe
proves something like the investigative
judgment or what have you as it stands.
I mean the simple answer is there's just
nothing in scripture that says that when
scripture talks about Christ on the
basis of his work entering a heavenly
sanctuary. I mean it says heaven itself,
right? heaven is portrayed as what
Christ entered into. And it doesn't
mention two phases to this. It's just
not there. Um I I know my other answers
were more involved and longer and all
that. I you know, but uh I don't know
where else to go with this other than
just to say uh you know, Hebrews 9, he
entered heaven itself. Uh and and
you know, the the crudely
anthropomorphic, I'm saying
anthropomorphic, there's probably a
better word for it. anthropomorphic more
strictly refers to describing God in in
you know
human ways but uh this crudely
literalistic corporeal whatever thing
that you just mentioned uh that's a new
one for me but uh that's you know but
the whole caporeal thing and then the
two-phase thing I I can't even begin to
imagine where that would come from
so we're going to look at some of those
supposed
and by the way and I meant to ask you
played that clip from the gentleman
earlier where he said and I wasn't sure
how he meant this. You know what he was
saying in context, but he he mentioned
it was one thing he didn't understand
from the Bible alone. Was he saying that
he didn't get this knowledge from the
Bible?
No, sorry. I I should have clarified. So
he right before that he plays or he says
a couple things. So he's talking about
this 1844 teaching and he says, "For the
mark of the beast, I had that down pat
for my Bible alone." He's talking about
when he first became an Adventist and he
goes through a number of their the state
of the dead, the mark of the beast, the
Adventist pillar doctrines.
He went through and he said, "I could
find all those from my Bible alone. I
knew I needed to know these from my
Bible alone." The one I struggled with
though was 1844.
I had to figure out how to get that from
the Bible alone. Well, this is why it it
pops back up for me now because like I
said, I can't even begin to imag like I
you know, I've heard other groups
mention some error and you know, give me
a few minutes, I can think of what they
might think would justify that, but this
one is truly unique in that I can't even
stop and and think, you know, you know,
again, when I mentioned I would expect
them to go to the book of Hebrews, it's
not because I think they've out material
there to justify their doctrine, but
only because it it speaks so much to the
priestly work of Christ, they would have
to deal with it, right? So, you'd expect
a group that has a peculiar view related
to these topics, they they'd have to get
around to, you know, somehow
reinterpreting texts in order to get
their doctrine in there. So, anyways, he
he's admitting the the the basic point.
I mean, he thinks he finally arrived at
a proper understanding of this and it's
warranted by the text, but he's at least
admitting he couldn't, you know, this
wasn't it wasn't there on the face of it
and it wasn't something easily attained
unto. And so, it's not by any stretch a
clear doctrine by his own admission.
Yeah. Well, and if you talk with
Adventist men, you're going to find the
average Adventist cannot explain this to
you. They don't know the system of
theology, but just even the
investigative judgment itself. I've
talked with pastors, uh, scholars, uh,
professors, uh, leoty. I've talked with
hundreds of Seventh Day Adventists and
the preface that the ones who do
understand the issues always, without
fail, always start the conversation by
saying, well, you need to understand
it's complicated.
That's how it starts because they know.
And there's been an evolution for those
that don't know um over the years.
Here's Dez Ford's uh I don't know if you
you probably don't know about the
history of Dez Ford, but he was a made
quite the waves and um the 1980s
regarding the 7th Adventist church and
kind of blowing the lid off of this. And
that book is dedicated essentially to
him executing Hebrews and basically um
tried to bring the their movement to a
position of abandoning this teaching
because he said it can't be proven. The
book of Hebrews decimates this teaching.
Well, they didn't listen because like
Cliff Goldstein said, um, if that were
to happen, the whole thing would
collapse. Um, so let's let's talk about
some of the verses that they're going to
use to to talk about this physical
tabernacle in heaven. Um, doesn't
Revelation 1 depict Jesus amongst the
candlesticks and use the imagery of the
earthly sanctuary and say that Jesus is
standing amongst those things in the
heavenly sanctuary? Doesn't that prove
this teaching?
Well, first, Revelation 1 is not a
picture of Jesus in heaven.
John just got through saying he's on the
island of Patmos, right, for the word of
God and so forth. And he hears a voice
behind him and then he turns and he sees
Jesus and he gives this description.
But furthermore, I mean, later in the
book, you do have John of course being
told, "Come up here." Right? But that
hasn't happened yet. Uh but all the
language even back in Revelation 1 is
apocalyptic. Uh you can't press the vast
majority of it literally. Uh Jesus is
holding stars in his right hand. I mean
how big is John that you know I mean uh
I mean I don't know maybe maybe you're
supposed to get the impression that that
he's seeing this vision of a incredibly
large Jesus. I I don't think that's the
way most people have read it. But in any
case John's on Earth. Jesus is appearing
to him. he hears his voice, he turns to
see him and the the lampstands are
actually defined later in the context.
It says the lampstands are the seven
churches. And so the point of the
symbolism is that Jesus is in the midst
of his people, which is something that
Jesus stated at uh the end of Matthew's
gospel, Matthew 28, he says, "Lo, I'm
with you always, even into the end of
the age." And then numerous other texts
of scripture speak of Christ's presence
with his people. I mean, that's the
heart of the promise of the covenant,
the Emanuel principle, God with us. Over
and over again in the Old Testament when
it's talking about what God is
accomplishing, what he's moving history
towards, it's the dwelling of God among
men. And that was something that Christ
came to accomplish, namely that he could
dwell in the midst of his people. And
certainly there's a consummated
realization of this in the future, but
it's already something that believers
participate in now. Christ is among us,
and that's what's being symbolized there
in Revelation 1. So, first, Revelation 1
is a vision to John on earth. Second,
it's interpreted as Jesus being in the
midst of the churches, right? And third,
it's apocalyptic imagery, which is
certainly not literal. I don't know
anybody that would take it literal in
any case where it doesn't pertain to
their distinctive or peculiar doctrine,
right? Like the sword protruding from
Christ's mouth, Christ looking like a
lamb that had been slain, you know,
seven horns. I don't think anybody's
expecting to see Jesus in heaven with
seven horns or a sword hanging out of
his mouth like a, you know, sometimes,
you know, I don't know, when I when I do
work, I have a highlighter and I'll have
it in my mouth because I'm using it so
often. Uh, yeah. not not seeing that.
Yeah. So, I to you brought up a point
that I always bring up with them, too,
is that the the lampstands are defined
for you. The last verse of chapter 1
says what the lampstands are, and it's
not literal lampstands. Um, I think
that's an inconsistent part of their
system is that they have to make things
literal when it's convenient to be
literal. Um, and then other times it's
it's not. But what about Anthony? We
were just talking about Hebrews. What
about Hebrews 9:23 and 24? It says,
"Thus it was necessary for the copy of
the heavenly things to be purified with
these rights, but the heavenly things
themselves with better sacrifices than
these. For Christ has entered not into
holy places made with hands, which are
copies of the true things, but into
heaven itself, now to appear in the
presence of God on our behalf."
Didn't heaven have to be purified as
well? Isn't that why there needs to be
an atonement going on? Because sin
started in heaven, right, with Lucifer.
And so didn't there need to be a
cleansing that takes place in heaven as
well, like the verse says there.
Well, so first of all, it says heaven
itself, which my point in in pressing
that is it's not talking about some
building in heaven. It's talking about
heaven itself as the counterpart to the
earthly tabernacle or temple, right?
that that uh symbolic
uh building either the portable, you
know, tabernacle or the brickandmortar
temple pictured the heavenly dwelling
place of God and not necessarily some
building that is in a particular region
of heaven. uh it's heaven itself and and
and the basic point of Hebrews 9 is that
Christ has provided the atonement
necessary to make the way for us to God.
Right? So in in Hebrews 9 uh it's
talking about the true atonement that
opens up the way into God's presence. Uh
so and I would think Hebrews 9 is a
problem for them anyways. I don't know
why they'd appeal to it. Uh because it
it's certainly not communicating the
idea of something being cleansed
1,800 years in the future or or
something that Jesus would begin doing
in the future. The text speaks of
something that Jesus already
accomplished, right? The the uh the
cleansing is something that already
happened.
Correct. So they'll I'll get some not
all I don't want to say all Adventists
uh use necessarily the same passages but
a lot of them will use this to say that
what's in heaven was a copy of what's on
the earth or what was on the earth or
rather what was on earth was actually a
copy of what is actually up in heaven.
And so these are the sort of things that
they'll proof text and latch on to out
of context um to say see so there is a
tabernacle in heaven and see there does
need to be a continuing atonement
because God is still reconciling all of
the universe to himself and he's going
through this process which ultimately
comes down to him having to as I
mentioned at the end of the steel man
vindicate his character and so they'll
point to this for typically those two
things but let's read Daniel 7. So note
also go ahead quick just note also where
it says now to appear in the presence of
God on our behalf. If that doesn't besp
speak Christ entering all the way in,
right? Uh if you're thinking of in terms
of some building and then uh the holy
place and then the most holy place and
and uh trying then to get this idea of
you know uh two stages and so forth
right there it's it's done away with now
to appear in the presence of God on our
behalf. Christ has gone all the way up
and in if you want to think in crudely
corporeal you know
ways.
Um so you want to know their response to
that
now doesn't mean now or now is being
spoken of from the perspective of when
these things happen or I don't know.
Nope. Um so you have to understand a
little bit of Adventist backstory on
this. Um, there's gonna be two things,
but the first one I want to say is you
brought
backtory
or sorry, a backstory. Um,
okay.
Um,
well, two things. One, it's because in
vision, Ellen White claimed that Jesus
was on a throne with the father in the
holy place and in 1844, they got up from
that throne and moved into the most holy
place. And she claimed to see this in
vision. So, um, for those that are
curious, I've actually done a stream
discussing this manuscript and this
vision and the fact that the SDA church
tried to keep this hush- hush for a
long, long time and then eventually the
manuscript had to be released, at least
what's available of it. And so, um, she
says in that manuscript as well that
when this act happened, the door of
mercy was shut. No one else could be
saved. Um, they pivoted off of that
after about seven years and then that is
what this doctrine was essentially born
out of. So it started with the shut door
theory that when Christ got up from the
throne that was in the holy place, moved
into the most holy place, the door of
mercy shut behind him and no one else
could be saved. But then the the flip
side here and the thing I always bring
up to them when they mention this verse
to talk about, well, what's on earth is
a copy of what was up in heaven. Well,
if that's the case, uh where was there
ever a throne in the tabernacle and when
was the presence of God ever in the holy
place?
If it's a direct copy, then there there
shouldn't Jesus wouldn't have gone to a
throne in the the holy place. It would
have been to like you mentioned into the
presence of God, which was contained in
the most holy place. So that's their
that's their response to that. Well, he
he did enter into the presence of God,
but the presence of God was in the holy
place, not the most holy place.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, let's read Daniel 7. This is a big
one. And then um I I'll have a question.
But let's read Daniel 7:9-14
cuz I want you to really expound upon
this here because this is a foundational
one for them. So he says, "As I looked,
thrones were placed and the ancient of
days took his seat. His clothing was
white as snow and the hair of his head
was pure wool. His throne was fiery
flames. Its wheels were burning fire."
This is the sort of thing they'll point
to as well to see. See, his throne has
wheels, so it moves around. So, he could
have been in the holy place and then
moved to the most holy place on the
throne with flaming wheels that Ellen
White said she saw. Its wheels were
burning fire. A steam of fire issued and
came out from before him. A thousand,000
served him, and 10,000 times 10,000
stood before him. The court sat in
judgment, and the books were opened. I
looked. Then because of the sound of the
great words that the horn was speaking,
and as I looked, the beast was killed,
and it destroyed and given over to a
burn uh over to be burned with fire. As
for the rest of the beasts, their
dominion was taken away, but their lives
were prolonged for a season and a time.
I saw in the night visions, and behold,
with the clouds of heaven, there came
one like the Son of Man, and he came to
the ancient of days, and was presented
before him. And to him was given
dominion and glory and a kingdom that
all peoples, nations, and languages
should serve. His dominion is an
everlasting dominion which shall not
pass away, and his kingdom one that
shall not be destroyed.
What is this talking about? Can you
explain to the audience what is being
said here?
Okay, so that's a big question. And I
don't know how much you want me to say,
but uh essentially the the vision has
reference to what happened at Christ's
ascension. It it certainly not talking
about some
event that took place well over a
millennia, almost two millennia in the
future, if that's what she thinks.
The the picture. So, so think about
this. So there are actually three texts,
this one being one of them that
really kind of present this sort of it's
almost like you know how the some some
old movies had all these still shots and
when you put them all together they they
give you this this appearance of motion
and so forth because you're seeing all
these pictures uh in a fast succession.
Well, if if you take Acts chapter 1
where it talks about Christ's ascension
up into heaven and then it talks about
the clouds enveloping him from their
sight. And then you look at Daniel 7
where it talks about this one coming in
upon or in the clouds of heaven to the
ancient of days. And then you look at
Revelation chapter 5, which is very
similar to what's going on here. Really,
Revelation 4 and five are very similar
to what's happening in Daniel 7. Because
in Revelation 4, you have this vision of
the Ancient of Days. It's not called the
Ancient of Days there, but the
description given is the same as that
given of the Ancient of Days in Daniel
7. that throne vision of of the Lord on
his throne is followed in chapter five
with
the weeping of John, right? The the
statement goes out that nobody was found
worthy in heaven or on earth and so
forth. Uh but then John's weeping is uh
stopped because it's pronounced that
here's the lamb, right? The lamb has
conquered. And so,
uh, this is where, uh, Daniel 7 tells
us, you know, I mean, all these things
together give us this running image is
what I'm I'm driving at. So, Christ
ascends into heaven. Uh, he receives
from the father all authority as the
risen incarnate savior, head of the
church, head over the universe, and now
begins to take the reigns of the
universe, if you will, and bring all
things into subjection to himself. And
so one huge problem for the Adventist
view and and probably for the
esquetology not only of Adventists but
others is that Christ's kingship isn't
something that awaits again. It's not a
thing that's being put off for 2,000
years.
It it's and and his kingdom is not
something that isn't uh a reality for
2,000 years in the future. Christ
entered upon his kingship. He sat down
at the right hand of the father. Right?
He has all authority in heaven on earth.
Everything is by right subject to him,
but is now being brought willingly or
unwillingly under his dominion. So
again, I mean, I don't know how much you
want me to get into, but I'm I'm, you
know, the basic point is that uh Daniel
7 is is talking about what happens upon
Christ's entrance into heaven and uh the
fact that he is now at the right hand of
the father exercising all all power and
authority. You there's a uh Daniel or
excuse me, Psalm 110 and Psalm 2 are
both related to this, right? Psalm two,
it speaks of the opposition to the son
and it says the son says, "Ask of me and
I'll give you the na," he's quoting the
father. "Ask of me and I'll give you the
nations as your inheritance, the ends of
the earth as your possession." And so at
the end of the psalm, the rulers of the
earth are warned to submit to the son,
kiss the son, lest he be angry and they
perish. And so the idea is that all
nations belong to this one. And so
everybody must submit to him or else
they're going to perish under him. And
then Psalm 110 speaks to the same thing.
He's seated at the right hand of the
father. And as seated, right, not
2,000 years in the future, as seated,
everything's being brought in under
subjection to him. And so, so likewise
in Daniel 7, in Daniel 7, uh, he has all
dominion and everything is being
subjected to him. There's just nothing
here of
uh you know this being prolonged for
2,000 years.
Well, it's funny you should say that
because one, you covered exactly what I
I wanted you to say is that this is
talking about at Jesus's ascension. As
you rightly recognize, the Adventist
Church has no concept of the kingdom of
God being present, that Christ is
already ruling and reigning. They'll use
the language like, well, he's king of
kings and lord of lords. um but not
really understanding the implications of
that to their system because now I want
to read what the Adventist Church
considers to be inspired exposition on
this passage.
For those unaware in selected messages
book three on page 122, Ellen White says
that her words are barricaded by a thus
sayaith the Lord. She specifically
mentions the desire of ages, patriarchs
and prophets and the great controversy.
So I want to read a quote now from the
great controversy, arguably her most
popular work. They're trying to give out
a billion copies, both digital and
physical, this year. So, I want to read
her exposition on this really quick and
get your thoughts.
So, she says, "Both the prophecy of
Daniel 8:14, which is what Cliff
Goldstein mentioned earlier, unto 2,300
days, then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed and the first angel's message,
fear God and give him glory or give
glory to him, for the hour of his
judgment has come." That's Revelation
14:6.
pointed to Christ's ministration in the
holy place to the investigative judgment
and not to the coming of Christ for the
redemption of his people and the
destruction of the wicked. So the
Millerites were initially interpreting
this passage which is the foundational
pillar text for them the 2300 evenings
and mornings using the dayear principle
wrongfully on this text. They arrived at
and a bunch of other wonky math. They
arrived at the year 1843 initially and
then 44 and they essentially all gave up
after it was over, the good majority of
them. But there was a small group, the
little flock that continued to seek
meaning in the disappointment. And so
that's what she's saying here is that
the mistake had been in the reckoning of
the prophetic periods, but or yeah, the
mistake had not been in the reckoning of
the prophetic periods, but in the event
to take place at the end of the 2300
days. Through this error, the believers
had suffered disappointment. Yet all
that was foretold by the prophecy and
all that they had and all that they had
any scripture warrant to expect had been
accomplished. At the very time when they
were lamenting the failure of their
hopes, the event had taken place which
was foretold by the message and which
must be uh fulfilled before the Lord
could appear to give reward to his
servants. Christ has come not to the
earth as they expected but as
foreshadowed in the type to the most
holy place of the temple of God in
heaven. He is represented by the prophet
Daniel as coming at this time to the
ancient of days. I saw in the night
visions and behold one like the son of
man came with the clouds of heaven and
came not to the earth but to the ancient
of days and they brought him near before
him.
So Anthony
Ellen White claims under inspiration
that this paricopy of Daniel 7 is about
1844.
Is it about 1844?
No, she's wrong. I mean, yeah. So,
uh,
yeah. So, we probably got to get into
the other the passage she mentions
there, I guess, at some point. But um
Daniel 7 is talking about four
successive kingdoms and uh the the
messianic
uh reign uh being inaugurated, if you
will, on their ashes. And uh we know
that Christ came during the time of the
fourth kingdom and uh he's at the right
hand of God since, right? Reigning until
he puts everything beneath his feet.
there there again there's just no you've
got to do something and I guess it's
that text right it's it's Daniel 84 you
got to do something to get that 1800
years in there because
I I'm noticing that you're uh and I
wanted this as well um folksy's not
anony's not super learned in this system
so he's hearing a lot of these things
here and this is the response that
people have people hear this stuff and
think what in the world is going on yet
in this system Your salvation hinges
upon understanding this. Ellen White
taught that you had to believe this if
you wanted to be saved because if you
reject it, you don't understand Christ's
high priestly work currently going on on
your behalf and you won't be able to
fill the role that he has intended for
you. So, you have to believe this to be
saved. And yet,
2,000 years almost of history and no one
else arrived at this conclusion. This is
why 1844 is such a lynch pin for them.
We're going to get into uh we're going
to watch a couple clips later, so you're
going to get to hear some of their one
of their more uh learned individuals on
this topic, but we're going to play
another clip from Cliff Goldstein as
well, where we're going to get into
specifically that that text, and you'll
see how they're utilizing it. But first,
there's two other things I want to bring
up. Are the sins of believers stored on
record in the books of heaven? Isn't
that what Daniel 7:10 is referring to?
It says that the books are going to be
opened, right?
Yeah. But in the in the context, it's
talking about again those those kingdoms
that preceded this kingdom. And there's
no indication that it's referring to the
uh books that would record the sins of
believers, which I you heard I heard the
quote that you gave before where this
this investigation pertains to
believers. But contextually the people
that are uh on the wrong side of this
judgment uh for whom these books have
any reference is is not the saints of
the most high. Uh but uh it also
couldn't be not again in the way that
she requires for you know her her
system. Scripture speaks very clearly of
uh the sins of believers being blotted
out. Even under the old covenant, people
could confidently
cry out to God to blot out their sins,
right? By virtue of what Christ would do
on the cross, which was a settled
certainty because God had decreed it,
right? God decreed the death of Christ.
For which reason John can speak of
Christ as the lamb slain from before the
foundation of the world. Or even if one
takes issue with that way of rendering
the verse, the fact of Christ's death
and and it as an atonement for sin being
predetermined by God is stated numerous
times over. Acts four being another
example. Uh very clearly scripture
speaks of this as something that God had
decreed and therefore as something that
was certain the benefits of which as a
consequence could be applied to people
even prior to the cross. That's why, you
know, the prophet Isaiah in Isaiah 43
could say, "I am the one who," well,
he's speaking for the Lord. I am the one
who wipes out, or you could render it
literally, I am he who blotss out your
transgression for my own sake. He's
speaking to the people of Israel. Right?
So, if he's speaking these words to the
people of Israel, then all the more is
it true for us or others who lived prior
to 1844.
The same thing is found in in Isaiah 44.
David in Psalm 51. He says, 'Be gracious
to me, oh God, according to your loving
kindness, according to the greatness of
your compassion, blot out my
transgressions. Uh this is the very
passage that Paul has in the background
in in Romans 4 when he's talking about
the present benefits that acrew to
believers who believe, right? those who
believe in Christ right now have their
sins blotted out. They're forgiven.
They're they're justified before the
Lord. Uh the same thing is stated in
Psalm 130, you know, where the the Lord
blotss out our iniquity. Um and by the
way, I mean again, I mean, not that it
needs to be stated after already hearing
from the Old Testament, but Acts three
and Colossians 2 also speak of uh sin or
the certificate of debt being blotted
out. Uh so again uh not seeing what Mrs.
White uh thinks she's getting by
prophetic inspiration.
Can you expound a little bit before
going to the next question um can you
expound a little bit on Colossians 2
there because the Adventist
understanding is um well and I often
tell former Adventists as well that um I
don't agree with their interpretation. I
also don't agree with the Adventist
interpretation. I think they're both
wrong. Um, one group believes that
what's being talked about there is the
ten commandments were being nailed to
the cross. To which the Adventist church
responds, "No, no, no. That was the
ceremonial laws that were being nailed
to the cross because the handwriting of
ordinances that stood against us was
what Moses put on the parchment. The Ten
Commandments were written by the finger
of God in stone housed inside the ark.
And the book on the outside from
Deuteronomy 31 that Moses wrote the the
law of Moses in that was only written on
parchment and that's what was nailed to
the cross. Now I know that that book
contained both the the law twice in both
Exodus and Deuteronomy. Um but that's
the claim that they'll make to say no it
was the ordinances and the other group
says no it was the ten commandments. But
you mentioned something differently
there. Can you explain that phrase
kurographon that's taking place in
Colossians 2?
What did I mention differently? because
I didn't have the Adventist views in
mind at all.
No, no, no. You're right. You said that
it was this it was the certificate of
debt.
Yeah. I mean, it's it's a legal term and
it's referring to what was hostile to
us. Uh so so taking a step back, Satan
in scripture is presented as an accuser.
And what's what's interesting is
sometimes people think of Satan as a
liar, which is true,
but for that reason, I think sometimes
miss an aspect of what's going on when
it it speaks of Satan is our accuser. It
simply isn't always the case that Satan
in his accusatory role is just lying
about people. when he is for example
talking about Job in the book of Job
he's he's trying to indict Jobuh
and
he's trying to bring him under the
Lord's scrutiny and he's saying for
example that Job is only doing what he
does evidencing fear of God because God
is good to him right if God were to
remove the hedge then Job would break
forth in the same kinds of sins that are
characteristic of other people. Uh and
so the point being that that Satan as an
accuser is accusing people on the basis
of things that they've done or that he's
alleging they would do uh under certain
circumstances. And what the
book of Colossians is saying, what
Paul's saying in Colossians is that the
very grounds for uh accusation is being
removed. that is the the the the
things that we are guilty of having
transgressed. Notice it speaks of uh it
cancelling the certificate of debt
consisting of decrees against us which
was hostile to us. Right? So I I don't
really know how you could limit that to
something like ceremonial ordinances. Uh
I've never in my life thought of uh
circumcision as something hostile to me
uh or dietary regulations being hostile
to me or or things pertaining to
clothing and whether you mix certain
things in your clothes as being hostile
to me. Uh but I am aware keenly aware of
my own transgression against the law of
God which is the basis the just basis
for being accused. But notice how Paul
goes on. He speaks of the having
canceled out the certificate of debt
consisting of decrees against us which
was hostile to us and he has taken out
of the way having nailed it to the cross
when he had disarmed the rulers in
authority he made a public display out
of them having triumphed over them
through him. So there you see th this uh
correlation or this you know how how
these satanic uh powers are are sort of
brought into view here. They're losing
their footing in terms of accusation.
You have a picture of this in Zechariah
3, right? When you have uh Joshua, the
high priest standing before the angel of
the Lord who's seated on a throne,
right? And he's standing there with
filthy garments is and Satan is standing
at his side to accuse him. So, Satan is
accusing him not on the basis of
something that's not true. He is filthy,
but the Lord remits his sin. He removes
his filthy garments from him. And also
you have a similar thing stated in
Revelation 12 when it talks about uh
Satan being cast down the accuser of the
brethren and the reason he is no longer
able to uh in any way prevail upon the
saints is because they have they
overcome him now because of the blood of
the lamb. Right? So the the basis for
accusation has been removed on account
of the the death of Christ blotting out
uh the certificate of death that was
against us. Does that does that address
your question?
It does. Yeah. Well, and you just you
pointed out something good there that
what's being said there is that that's
an evidence of sin being blotted out. Um
it's not just something like oh the
handwriting of ordinance. They cling on
to typically the King James version like
the King James um translation because
they like how it says handwrit
handwriting of ordinances and they'll
say Deuteronomy uses that same phrase.
So what was nailed to the cross was the
parchment that the the ordinances were
written on. But what's actually being
said there is that sins were canceled
out. Um the sin debt that we had
incurred.
The idea of handwriting, it's it's
referring to a legal document. Yeah.
It's judicial terminology and so just
trying to Yeah. That that doesn't work
what they're trying to do.
No.
But what about First John 1:9? Doesn't
First John 1:9 say that if we confess
our sins, he's faithful and just to
forgive us our sins? So, doesn't this
prove that our sins are still being
dealt with by Jesus in heaven and we
need to confess every one of them if we
want them expuned from our record?
Well, did that begin in 1844 or
I mean, I'm just asking for the
Adventist position here. Is that
something that began in 1844?
Yeah, you'd have to ask the individual
Adventist. That's the question that I
always ask them typically with any of
these any of these.
I'm not thinking of 1844.
Yeah. It's not in his mind at all.
Yeah. uh he he's like that Clifford
fellow at the beginning, you know, he he
never saw that and uh never mentioned it
in his writings or anything else, right?
He's he's talking to believers at his
time saying if you confess your sins,
he's faithful and just to forgive them.
And here uh John of course teaching in
his gospel as well as in his epistles,
but in his gospel that Christ by his
death took away sin. Christ is the lamb
of God who takes away the sin of the
world, right?
uh but also he mentions how
believing in Christ already delivers us
from future judgment. Right? Those those
who believe in Christ, he says have
passed out of death into life. And he
uses similar phraseology to speak about
uh will not come under judgment. Right?
And then he says this is the verdict.
Light has come into the you know he he
uses this judicial terminology but for
the believer this is all put in the
past. Right? We have passed out of death
unto life. we will not come on into
judgment. And so for John, the judicial
aspect of this is all in the past. But
that doesn't mean that we can't speak in
a relational sense of sins being
forgiven, right? I mean, I have uh kids
and I can speak of forgiving my kids,
but that doesn't mean that they're under
judicial
uh guilt or anything like that that
needs to be blotted out, right? Right. I
mean, there's there's a difference
between a person who's on the wrong side
of the law, who's therefore guilty, who
needs to be uh declared just and and put
in the right, you know, in right
standing with the law, and then somebody
who subsequent to that, let's say, is
adopted into a family. In that context,
you could speak of, right, a person
sinning and being forgiven. That's a
relational rather than a judicial
reality. Does that make sense? You
understand what I'm talking about? The
Yeah,
might have been awkwardly or poorly
stated, but uh yeah, there's there's a
difference between a a criminal who's
being justified before the bar of
justice and a son who's
a a has a leg, you know, already has
legal standing in the family as an
adopted son sinning and being forgiven.
Right? So that it's it's not the idea of
uh sins being judicially blotted out in
John.
This is one of the typical things that
I'll try and explain to I mean I talk
with like I said hundreds of Adventists
um each week and many reach out who have
questions and this is always one thing I
always try to point out to them is that
oftentimes the Adventist position has to
latch on to a very unid-dimensional
aspect of a verse that they think is
helping them but they haven't. It's kind
of like the the guy who um you know at
work who maybe like just
thinks an idea is good but hasn't
thought it out well enough. So like
proposes it before thinking it out well
enough and then once people start like
analyzing it you realize okay well maybe
that wasn't the greatest idea. It's like
that sort of thing. It's have you really
thought this through? Because like you
mentioned 1844 um is that what John has
in view here is that at this in after
1844 that's when this process is going
to begin taking place in heaven. Um so
be confessing now because they have this
whole theory of transference where when
you confess your sin it is transferred
to the heavenly sanctuary because it's
transferred there to be documented in
this book that's being opened in this
investigative judgment. And Jesus is
going down the list and if you haven't
confessed the sin, he's going to skip
over it and it will remain on your
books. After this investigative judgment
is over and what they call the time of
trouble begins, the period of probation
will close. They have a whole theory
about probation and you will have to
stand before Almighty God without an
intercessor during the courtroom scene.
Satan will be there as the accuser.
Jesus will move from being the uh
mediator to being the advocate. He'll
only be advocating for those who made it
through the investigative judgment.
Because in this trial, when Satan is
making his accusations, Jesus will be
able to open the books and show, "Nope,
their record is clean. I'm just fair in
saving them." And that will silence the
accusations of Satan. So any person that
has any sins on the books, he's not
going to be able to do that for because
Satan's accusation will stand. So that's
why there's this whole theory around you
have to confess every single sin. Um,
even though many of them are going to
try and say, "Well, I don't believe that
aspect or I don't necessarily believe
that." That's what Ellen White taught.
I I was going to add then, and you were
kind of getting into it towards the end
there, but how scrupulous are they? What
do they mean by confessing every sin? I
mean, when you think of David keenly
aware of God's law and how exhaustive it
is in, you know, and pure and how that's
not true of us, not even the best of
saints. David in Psalm 19, for example,
can talk about hidden faults and he
prays to God to keep him from great
transgressions.
But the sense you get from David's
confessions and other places in the
Bible is that there's this awareness of
sins that you aren't even aware of. Not
that you don't know what the criteria
for calling something a sin is, but you
may have committed something so
inadvertently that it didn't even
register in your own mind. Or being a
fallen, infallible person, you may well
have forgotten it. You may have done it
and and forgotten you did it. I mean, h
I I just can't imagine the conscience of
the average Adventist if they're really
taking this stuff full boore, could it
possibly allow them any rest at night?
Well, that's I'm wondering.
And that's the facts, brother. That's
how it is. That's how it was growing up
in this movement. When you're in a truly
uh, you know, old paths
classic historic believing Seventh Day
Adventist, you don't have any peace.
You're constantly worried about if
there's any sins that you forgot to
confess, etc. So you asked what the
standard is. So I will just um
tell you me throw this in though. So
what what I'm thinking what normally
happens with people when like if you
look at a works righteousness system,
you either get people that will try and
tone down the demands of God's law and
pretend that it doesn't require as much
as it really does. Or they will turn a
blind eye to much of their sins and and
uh you know try and hide things and and
so they'll become very self-righteous,
right? uh where where they're not
willing to acknowledge certain sins. I'm
just I'm just thinking through these
implic even in context where people
otherwise are hearing the gospel.
There's some elements of this sometimes
that you know will affect people uh that
that they have to you know keep hearing
the word to to get past. But you know in
a system where this is actually being
taught. I just can't imagine, you know,
what this looks like because again,
they've either got to pretend that God's
law is not as demanding as it is or that
they're pulling off what they're not
pulling off.
Yeah. So, it's only the letter of the
Ten Commandments, which they're not
keeping that either, but they think many
of them think they are. Um, they believe
they're the commandmentkeeping church.
So, they're going to point to Revelation
and say, "Well, this end times remnant
church says it has the spirit of
prophecy, which is the testimony of
Jesus, and they keep the commandments
and the faith of Jesus." So, they've
written they've read all sorts of things
into those terms. Um, and that's
essentially how they kind of weasel this
around to say, "We're the one true
church because we keep the ten
commandments." So this is like a
foundational aspect to their movement,
but they're defining that and lowering
like you've said the actual standard um
to just the letter of the ten
commandments. And even then, if you talk
to many of them, so for example,
idolatry, that's going to be classified
as I didn't bow down to any statues.
It's like that level of of, you know,
it's not running as deep as well, was
God uh first in every thought, deed,
motive, and word today. it's not at that
level where it where where it truly is
um how high the standard actually is. So
um but then you're also going to find
them too on that other side of the
spectrum that you mentioned. So it's
kind of a mixed bag because not all
Adventist pastors or Adventists are
going to affirm this as foundational as
it is to the system. They have in their
movement liberal and conservative
Adventists. And then now there's kind of
like a third strain that's kind of
breaking off that has started to develop
over the past couple decades where
they're trying to basically be like
evangelical Adventists and they don't
tend to hold to this stuff or if they do
like Cliff Goldstein in that same video.
I'm going to be reviewing that on the
channel by the way folks um in full in a
couple weeks. Um, so you'll see in that
video, but he he goes on in there to try
and say, um, the only way to make it
through this judgment is if you're
clothed in Christ's righteousness there,
no, you can't bring any works. You can't
bring anything. Well, he's a a
fundamental belief touting seventh day
Adventist. Well,
uh, Cliff, my question for you would be
if you agree with what Ellen White says
here, because what he presents in that
discussion is that, oh, it's just this
event that takes place before the second
coming. And we basically are believing
like evangelicals do that it's only by
Christ and it's only by being in Christ.
That's how he presents it. So, you asked
the question earlier, how strict is it?
And there's tons of quotes on this. This
is just one of many, but I want to use
the same book, Great Controversy.
Remember folks, barricaded by a thus
saith the Lord. And this is only for
believers. Remember, this is only for
professed believers all the way back to
Adam.
How solemn is the thought, day after
day, passing into eternity bears its
burden of records for the books of
heaven. Words once spoken, deeds once
done, can never be recalled. Angels have
registered both the good and the evil.
The mightiest conqueror upon the earth
cannot call back the record of even a
single day. Our acts, our words, even
our most secret motives all have their
weight in deciding our destiny for will
or woe. Though they may be forgotten by
us, they will bear their testimony to
justify or to condemn.
That's the standard.
Anything you've forgotten, it's
documented in that book because you've
had an angel assigned over you at your
profession. an angel has been assigned
over you to document down your sins to
then report them back to
So, so how do they deal with a sin they
might have forgotten?
Yeah, that's the question I ask them.
I mean, there's there's no way how do
you recover that? I mean, it almost
sound you'd almost hope there's
something like uh not that Scientology
exactly. I mean, it's it's poppycock as
well, but you know, they they have this
idea of
things from their past being cleared,
right? and they go through this whole
process. I don't know if you know much
about Scientology, but there's this
whole process of clearing things from
the past. Uh, so I'm just curious how
somebody in this system would deal with
this gnawing thought. It would have to
be a constant gnawing thought if they're
at all sensitive to sin. And I mean, I
don't think there's any problem of
taking sin seriously and wanting to root
it out and all that kind of stuff. But
when you're laboring under this idea
that I've got to remember every sin in
order that I might confess every sin, in
order that I might be absolved of it or
it be blotted out or what have you, then
it goes well beyond that, right? You you
you'd have to have every wake. I mean, I
I just I'm aware of other works
righteousness systems where I think,
man, if I was part of that system, I I'd
be walking around with a book and I'd be
making sure I'm writing everything down
and tabulating everything and and making
sure that uh nothing's slipping my
notice. Right? You think of Luther when
he was realizing
some of the inherent problems in what
had developed out of the medieval period
in in Roman Catholicism. what what was
bothering him was he would leave the
confessional thinking I forgot one and
he'd go back right but I'm sure Luther
was in that whole situation constantly
annoyed at the the you know the sin that
he forgot coming back to his remembrance
and then he he's not at the confessional
so he has to do it tomorrow and he's
worried at night that he might die
before he gets there and you know so
anyways just just trying to think of the
Adventist in in this context um I would
think there's no hope you you can't
possibly think that you've remembered
all your sins.
Well, and like I said, there's going to
be many Adventists on this point that
are going to say, "Well, no, that's not
what she meant." No, we don't believe
that. I don't believe that because deep
down they know that this is crazy. But
this is what they taught. You can read
the pioneers who were a lot closer
obviously in line with Ellen White and
they've gone through a number of shifts,
man. They're they're in this phase now.
I I call it the damage control
conference. It's called the Hold the
Line Conference. That's that clip from
Cliff Goldstein. That was from a month
ago, a month and a half ago. Um, they're
in damage control. YouTube channels like
mine are popping up, ministries like
mine are popping up. Um, and they're
going to have to start addressing these
things. And so, they're trying to now
put a more evangelical veneer over the
system. So, you're going to get a lot of
people who are going to say, "No, I
don't believe that. Obviously, we're all
sinners." Um, but that's an
inconsistency in their system because
the time of trouble is going to come and
you're going to have to be able to stand
before Almighty God without an
intercessor and you're going to have to
be sinlessly perfect. So that's why when
Cliff Goldstein in that presentation
tries to present this thing as just, oh,
it's just a unique event that we
believe, but we still believe that we're
saved the same way that all other
evangelicals are. You don't, he's like,
we're all sinners, you know, we we we
try our best. We strive. And it's like,
no, dude. You're you're not presenting
the full scope of your system here.
You're now essentially admitting that
the time of trouble is not going to have
to be something you have to be able to
pass by being sinlessly perfect. Satan's
accusations then are they going to be
able to stand? Like it's just it's a
mess. But moving forward here, another
verse. What about 2 Corinthians 5:10?
Isn't Paul speaking to Christians in
this verse? And he says, "For we all
must appear before the judgment seat of
Christ so that each one may receive what
is due for what he's done in the body,
whether good or evil." So since he is
speaking to believers here,
doesn't that mean that there must be a
distinct judgment for them prior to the
second coming?
Well, first of all, my understanding so
far of LG White's view is that it has
reference to eternal judgment, right?
eternal wheel or woe, whether a person
will be with God forever or not. And
Paul has made it clear in his
correspondence to the Corinthians that
the works of believers are brought into
view with respect to rewards, not with
respect to entrance into heaven. Right?
So Paul speaks of a person's works being
uh if you will uh scrutinized not not at
some 1844 date or something like that. I
mean it just doesn't have this in view
that's nowhere taught in scripture. But
he's he's talking about uh certain works
that will have been done for the glory
of God according to his law and from
faith and a regenerate heart. uh and
then other works that are not so uh
pristine if you will right some works
will have been done for self-flattering
reasons and these sorts of things will
go unrewarded right they'll be burned up
Paul says uh so Paul's not talking about
an a a judgment upon believers that will
determine whether they go to heaven or
not but he does believe that believers
will be rewarded according to what
they've done and and the rewards that
the believer gets will themselves be an
evidence of whether they were in Christ,
whether they had regenerate hearts. Uh
so that that's true. I mean Paul does
does speak of works playing a role in
that sense. Works are uh vindicatory,
right? They they vindicate the claim of
a person to be in Christ. U but they
don't justify or condemn.
That's the key. And that's why this
thing is a false gospel because it's
ultimately twisting how a person is
reconciled to God. And I've had
discussions on my channel, especially
this week in particular. Um don't know
if there's any reason for that, but uh a
number of Adventists have argued this
with me and said, "No, no, no. We don't
believe that we're reconciled by our
works." But they don't believe that
they're reconciled to God yet. And then
you start pressing them on this whole
chain of things. And they say, "Well, we
just believe that reconciliation is a
long process.
It's something that's taking place over
a long period of time." And that
includes us along with all of the
creation. And since all the creation
isn't reconciled yet, that means we're
not reconciled to God yet. Well, then I
ask them, okay, well then during this
process, you're essentially espousing a
two-tier system of justification. This
sounds like medieval Romanism. this idea
of I'm initially justified by grace
alone through faith alone of course but
then over time depending on what I'm
doing that will determine whether my
final justification actually plays out
and so that's essentially what is being
said here is that this investigative
judgment is inserting a two-tier system
of justification where they'll tell you
of course it's by grace through faith
alone but then one's behavior while
they're on that path will now because in
their you um in this great controversy,
you have to uh help God in the great
controversy by vindicating his character
and demonstrating that this accusation
of Satan that took place in heaven
before the earth was even created. Um
this isn't in the Bible, by the way.
This is from the great controversy
narrative. Um Satan began accusing God,
saying his law is not fair. And this all
started because Jesus was exalted to be
made equal with the father. And Lucifer
became jealous. So it wasn't his pride
initially that caused it. It was the
fact that Jesus was exalted to be made
equal which triggered this jealousy in
him that led to a rage. Well, part of
the accusations that he supposedly
started making was that the law of God
cannot be kept perfectly. So, they
believe that Jesus came to be the way
shower to show you that it can be kept.
And so, through the help of the Holy
Spirit, the helper that they love to
point to that verse then when Jesus
says, "I'll send you another helper."
They say that the Holy Spirit has been
sent to essentially empower you now to
be able to do to keep the law perfectly.
And that's part of the good news is that
you now have the ability and can do that
and silence the accusations of Satan
vindicating the character of God in the
controversy. So that's kind of some
underlaying foundation behind why they
have this whole theory here because the
investigative judgment is only one of
the steps in their seven steps of the of
the sanctuary. So they have a whole
theory around this and this is step
five. It's where he's at now. Um but in
that previous Ellen White quote if you
remember from before she mentioned and
you asked a question about it Daniel
8:14 and the 2300 evenings and mornings.
So I'll have a question for you. But
before doing that I want to play a clip
here from Cliff Goldstein. It's about
four minutes or so long. So let's listen
and then I'll ask you the question after
that.
And you know, our church,
our church was founded upon a text
that I suspect
the vast majority of you don't think
about all that much.
And that text is Daniel 8:14.
and he said unto me for 2,300
days
then shall the sanctuary be cleansed.
Now based on this text a Baptist named
William Miller
believed that in 1844
October 22nd to be sure to be precise
Jesus Christ was going to come return to
the earth. Okay, obviously Miller was
wrong and the Millerite movement pretty
much disappeared into history
with one notable exception.
A group of people over the next few
years looked again at the prophecy
and eventually it became apparent what
Miller's mistake was.
And really in one sense it was an easy
mistake to make if you parallel the
prophecies of Daniel 2, Daniel 7, and
Daniel 8 together. And they are parallel
prophecies. You get, if you saw
yesterday, a sequence. All right, put
the slide up. Put the slide up for me.
You get a sequence of
Okay,
you guys. Okay, good. You get a sequence
of world events.
Babylon across me to Persia, Greece,
Rome, pre-advent judgment, sanctuary
being cleansed, and then God's eternal
kingdom. And the cleansing of the
sanctuary
parallels the pre-advent judgment. And
this is followed immediately by Jesus
return, God's eternal kingdom being set
up. We looked at that quite a bit
yesterday. Okay. And Miller's mistake,
and if you read the text, you can see
why he made it so much was to confuse
this massive judgment scene in heaven
and with what it results in, which is
the second coming of Jesus.
Okay? He saw the parallel between the
sanctuary and the judgment, but he kind
of conflated them and he thought that
that would meant God's eternal kingdom
at the end of time. And he was obviously
wrong. But look at these texts here.
Look at these verses. I want you to look
at these judgment verses. Okay, you
could take that down.
Okay, Daniel 7 9-10.
I watched till the thrones were put in
place
and the ancient of days was seated. His
garment was white as snow. His hair on
his head was like pure wool. His throne
was a fiery flame. Its wheels a burning
fire. A fiery stream issued and came
forth from before him. thousand,000
ministered unto him. 10,000 times 10,000
stood before him. The court was seated
and the books were open. And then Daniel
7:21
and 22. I was watching and the same
horde made war against the saints
prevailing against them until the
ancient of days came and a judgment was
made in favor of the saints of the most
high and and the time came for the
saints to possess the kingdom. As I said
yesterday and repeat again, there was
this massive judgment scene in heaven.
And right after this judgment scene in
heaven, the time came for the saints to
possess the kingdom. And that happens
after Jesus comes back. So you've got
this massive judgment scene in heaven
before the second coming of Jesus.
before the second advent. Hence, you
have what we call a pre-advent
judgment.
All right.
So, in light of what we looked at
earlier,
is he correct? Does Daniel 8:14
perfectly parallel Daniel 2 and Daniel 7
evidencing this pre-advent investigative
judgment?
No. And I there's a I don't know two
dozen problems here.
But but one thing is back in Daniel 2,
it mentions that the kingdom, right? It
mentions these four kingdoms and then
another uh it mentions that one being
set up
at at the time, right, of the fourth
kingdom. It says in uh Daniel 2:44, it
says, "In the days of those kings, the
God of heaven will set up a kingdom
which will never be destroyed." So, it's
not talking about an event that would
take place 1,844,
you know, years later. It had to be
during the time of that fourth kingdom,
which isn't still reigning on the earth.
Uh, Daniel 7, same problem. and then
Daniel 8. And I I'm assuming this is
what you're primarily after when you ask
if they're all exactly parallel. You
know, if you go through Daniel 8, the
the person in view there when it's
talking about
bringing an end uh to the regular
sacrifice and so forth is Antiochus
Epiphanies. I mean, if you're just
following the historical flow, right?
So, uh I mean, there there's more
problems here. I don't know if you want
me to get into them yet, but I mean
there's not an exact parallel at that
point at least.
Yeah. So, they're aware of the Antichas
Epiphany's reality. Um, they reject that
obviously. Um, and Cliff actually
mentions that in there. He had two
speaking engagements at this event.
We're watching the second one. The clip
from earlier was from the first one. Um,
and it's titled 1844 Made Simple. Uh, he
wrote a book years ago that's still in
print and that's the title of the book.
And um so he speaks on this a lot. This
is kind of his hot topic, if you will.
And that that is their explanation of
how they try to read this idea into
scripture. So they're going to use a
historicist approach and they're going
to point to saying that the uh the 2300
evenings and mornings had to do from the
time of Artic Xerxes 1 in like what 526
or something like that is how you land
then at 1844. Cliff was actually wrong
there. Um, William Miller wasn't saying
October 22nd, 1843. Um, it was just the
year 1843. And then in the spring of
1844, this crackpot by the name of
Samuel Snow, who thought he was the
reincarnation of Elisha the prophet
before the second coming, um, he used
all this sort of wonky Jewish math and
claimed to arrive specifically at the
date, um, October 22nd, 1844. William
Miller never accepted any of this stuff
post what was going on with all that but
um it was actually Samuel Snow that came
up with that. Not necessarily William
Miller. Uh anything else to add on that
point?
Yeah. So actually I mean the the huge
problem that that's glaring to me I mean
the verse just doesn't allow for this in
in a whole host of ways. I mean, number
one,
so I I mean, I did look a little bit at
this idea that Daniel 14 is relevant to
their system. And part of what I
gathered is they're they're trying to
claim that it's talking about 2,300
days. And then they're saying that a day
stands for a year, which is the sort of
thing that you could argue is is present
elsewhere. But the problem is that it
doesn't use the term day here. And
moreover, it it doesn't even I mean what
it says literally is evening morning.
And note that uh evening it doesn't say
evening and morning. It doesn't say
evenings and mornings though I I do
think it's clear that it's talking about
many. But that the idea is from the
grammar that you have it's it's a
reference contextually to the the daily
sacrifice in Jerusalem at the temple.
There was a morning and evening
sacrifice when Jesus died. When he's put
on the cross the gospels draw attention
to this. They mention that he was put on
the cross at 9, right? And then uh he
was taken down uh or he he died at at 3.
And that was the time of the morning and
evening sacrifice. you have that
correspondence there in the gospels but
yeah so it doesn't use the the necessary
term from which you could get a day year
principle it it says evening morning and
as I take it and I know there's
discussion here the one thing there's
there's no discussion about among
commentators is there's no question that
it doesn't have anything to do with what
the adventists are talking about but one
could argue that it's either referring
to 2300 days which I don't see how it
works or you could say that It's
referring to 1150.
Uh because the idea is that it it's it's
counting the way the grammar is you
evening morning 2300s.
It's it's saying together, right? These
two things. So you have,50
morning offerings, 1150 evening
offerings. And then when you look at
that, I mean it uh the correspondence of
the of the time frame works out pretty
nicely, right? you have uh you know the
uh Anton's Epiphanies ceasing the the
offering and then subsequent to that
offering a pagan sacrifice. Oh, I mean
the other problem with this verse is
that it's not talking about anything
being cleansed. That has nothing to do
with the verse. The the Hebrew term that
would need to be used for something
pertaining to cleansing is just not used
here. The the Hebrew word that's used
here is the word saddak which means
righteous but here it's in the nifal
which means to be putright and the idea
is that here here's the it's not a
heavenly temple either right which in
the context how could it be a heavenly
it's talking about it being trampled
underfoot who's trampling underfoot the
heavenly court right I mean so many
problems I and and I'm not the guy that
sits around thinking about adventist
stuff all day long I looked at this the
other day and I'm like there's just no
way you're going to get the 1844
investigative judgment out of this
right? Uh it's talking about this uh
being trampled underfoot. Clearly not a
heavenly uh temple. It's not talking
about 2,300 days or years, but evening
morning sacrifices.
And uh it's talking about
everything being put right at the end of
this period. meaning it had been, you
know, everything had been brought to a
grinding halt and had been used for
pagan purposes now. And so again, I
mean, I don't know how many reasons that
was to say there's a problem here. And
I'm sure there's more if I spent another
10 minutes thinking about it.
Yeah. Yeah, I mean, you hit on one that
I always hit on and that's that this
regardless of of what it is, the
Adventists like to oftentimes just
assume that their position is the
default one and you have to prove that
that's not the case when no, the reality
is is the onus is on you. Um, but what I
always point out to them is that the
2300 is talking about something that a
wicked figure will do and cease. It's
about a period of time, how long
something will take place and then end.
It's not about how long it's going to be
until something begins, let alone
something in heaven. You would never get
from that verse, which is why William
Miller didn't. He believed that the
sanctuary to be cleansed was the earth
and that God was going to return and
cleanse the earth with fire and that was
going to be the cleansing of the the
sanctuary. Well, then when this whole
thing pivoted, um, it turned to, well,
no, it was actually that Jesus
desecrated the sanctuary in heaven by
taking in the sin laden blood of
sinners. And it's the sin laden blood
that defiled the sanctuary in heaven
that now they have pivoted off of that
obviously because that was one of those
I think um you didn't quite think this
one through well enough before putting
this out there. Well, they claim that
the little horn in the wicked little
horn in the passage is papal Rome. So
then the question becomes how did paple
Rome defile heaven and trample underfoot
heaven?
So there's just a number of problems and
the text isn't going to change. they
know about these problems. Um, which is
why they had things like the revelation
and problems in Revelation and Daniel
committee which left with uh no minutes
because they couldn't uh deal with any
of the problems. But with that said,
let's now play the next clip. We're
going to transition to another guy who's
very prominent in um the Adventist world
for teaching on this stuff. He has a
ministry called Secrets Unsealed TV on
uh YouTube. His name is Steven Boore.
We've talked about Boore on the channel
before. We'll be doing some response
videos to him as well in the future. But
I want to play a small clip here because
he covers one of their other favorite
passages to go to and uh then we'll get
into that.
See here.
Uh in Matthew chapter 22, we have a
first call
to the wedding of Jesus with his people.
uh and this invitation is given to the
Jewish nation. The Bible tells us that
the invitation was rejected. Then in the
parable, Jesus dies. He sheds his blood
on the cross and another invitation is
given to the Jewish nation. And that's
exactly what happened. You know, when
they rejected Christ, there were still
messengers that went to the Jews
afterwards. And they also rejected the
message. So then the gospel goes to the
Gentiles. It goes to the highways and
the byways, which is a way of speaking
of the gospel, the preaching of the
gospel going to the whole world. And as
people accept the message, the wedding
chamber is filled with guests. Now uh it
doesn't mean that the guests are present
in heaven in the chamber where the
judgment is going to take place. No, the
fact is that when they accepted Jesus
Christ, their names were registered in
the book of life. So in other words,
even though they are on earth, they
actually are spoken of as being in the
wedding chamber. Now, uh that's a very
important point. So then what happens is
the king comes out and he comes to
examine all of those who are in the
wedding chamber, all of those who are in
in the chamber where the court
proceeding is going to take place.
Okay. So before we go any further on
this, let's bring up Matthew 22
because this is one of their favorite
ones to go to to say that the wedding
feast, the parable of the wedding feast
is talking about the investigative
judgment.
So while I bring this up here, Anthony
is the parable of the banquet or the the
the wedding feast in Matthew 22
about an investigative judgment.
Well, you're yeah, you you know, I'm
going to say no. Uh,
it's talking about the outward call of
the gospel, the the general gospel call
that goes forth certainly to the Jews,
first to the Jews, then to the Gentiles,
and those who respond to the call in
faith are then admitted to the wedding
feast. Uh the whole point of the parable
is that it's only those who receive the
gospel call that have a right to enter
in and and not necessarily those who are
otherwise say for ethnic reasons you
know part of what you know one would
have thought would have you know been
part of the you know the company that
belonged to that that entourage but uh
uh yeah just it isn't there's there's
nothing about an investigative judgement
here. The whole the whole issue turns on
whether or not they're clothed in
wedding garments. And I I don't
understand how this would work into
their system when they talk about uh
sins being blotted out or not. Um when
do they think people are clothed in
these wedding garments?
That's the million-dollar question. And
this is something I press SDAs on
because they're going to want to tell
you. No, no, no. Ellen White regularly
talked about being clothed in the
righteousness of Christ. clothed in the
righteousness of Christ in Christ in his
sanctuary. And uh I can't remember the
other book off the top of my head, but
I've talked about this on the show
before. Uh maybe I can put this down in
the comments or something um afterward,
but no, it's after one makes it through
the investigative judgment, they are
then given the robe of righteousness.
So you have to make it through the
judgment and be found worthy and then
you receive that garment. So it's post
that taking place. But the reason I
asked you about that and I paused where
I did is because I wanted to hear what
you had to say very clearly. This is
about the call of the gospel going to
the nations.
Correct?
Mhm. Yeah.
Okay. So now let's go back and let's
hear Stephen give the Adventist
exposition of this text. And I say the
Adventist exposition because all he's
doing is regurgitating what's in the SDA
Bible commentary, which is essentially
regurgitating Ellen White and all the
times that she commented on this
specific passage.
Let's read about this in Matthew chap 22
and vers 11 to13.
It says, "But when the king came in to
see the guests,"
now that word see, it's not the best
translation. Uh it's the Greek word the
which really means to examine, to
scrutinize. So now the king comes in to
examine the guests, those who accepted
Jesus Christ as savior, whose names are
written in heaven. They're present there
at the wedding, not in person. They're
present there through their records.
They're present there because their name
is in the book of life. And so now each
guest is examined. And as the king comes
out to examine the guests,
suddenly a a problem appears. It says,
"But when the king came in to see or to
examine the guests, not only one guest,
the guests, he saw a man there who did
not have on a wedding garment." What is
the wedding garment? It's the
righteousness of Christ. So there was an
individual there in the chamber. His
name obviously written in the book of
life because he claimed to accept Jesus
Christ as savior, but he didn't have the
wedding garment. He didn't truly have
the righteousness of Christ. I hope
you're understanding what I'm saying.
Verse 12. So he said to him, "Friend,
how did you come in here without a
wedding garment?"
Now, does that mean that individuals are
going to sneak into heaven? In other
words, when Jesus comes, he takes his
people to heaven and then the king comes
out and he looks at all the guests and
he says, "Hey, how did you make it here
to heaven without having the wedding
garment?" Of course not. Nobody's going
to be in heaven and then be cast out of
heaven. What it's talking about is that
every believer's name is written the
book of life and then their cases are
examined to see if they truly accepted
the righteousness of Jesus Christ if
they're covered with his righteousness.
There will be some who are not. And so
it says in verse 12, "So he said to him,
friend, how did you come in here without
a wedding garment?"
And he was speechless. There's not going
to be any excuses, folks. Then the king
said to the servants, "Bind him hand and
foot, take him away, and cast him out
into outer darkness. There will be
weeping and nashing of teeth."
Now, there's two other passages that we
find in scripture that are very
important in understanding this concept
of the pre-advent judgment. You see, the
wedding of Jesus in heaven is when every
one of those who claim to have believed
in Christ has been examined and Christ's
bride is made up. In other words, all of
those who were genuine believers is made
up. Or another way of saying it, once
his kingdom is made up, because his
kingdom is composed of all of his
followers, the judgment has shown who is
a follower of Jesus. Once that has taken
place, then the wedding occurs. But the
wedding is not when Jesus comes to marry
his people on earth. The wedding takes
place when every case has been decided.
The kingdom of Jesus is complete. The
the the bride of Jesus is complete
because the judgment has revealed who
belongs to his kingdom, who is part of
his bride. And then in heaven, Jesus
marries his bride or Jesus takes over
the kingdom which is composed of all of
his followers, all of his believers. And
only then will Jesus come to pick up his
bride.
Okay, so there was a lot there, I know,
but that's their explanation of what's
going on there. they have to read this
judgment into all sorts of places in all
sorts of passages. Um, but primarily
because that's the explanation that
Ellen White gave. You'll notice he
mentioned only those who have Christ
righteousness, they are great at using
Christian language. They do not mean the
same thing that we mean. That's a
discussion probably for another time.
I've talked about that on the channel
before, but it's um when they say the
righteousness of Christ, it's not a
one-time, you know, declared legally
righteous imputed with the active and
passive obedience of Jesus. Um it is
that you are essentially given a clean
slate and then over the course of
progressive sanctification, Jesus is
essentially imputing grace. They would
say imparting imparting grace to you,
making up the difference. And it should
be on on your trajectory that you're
eventually getting to a point where that
doesn't have to happen anymore because
you're in a sinlessly perfect state. And
thus, you have the righteousness of
Jesus.
Your righteousness at that point mirrors
Jesus's righteousness. And you're living
a life like he did, showing that the law
can be kept. That's what they mean by
the righteousness of Christ as well. So,
it's not the same thing that we mean
when we talk about the imputation of of
a foreign alien righteousness like in
Philippians 3:9 and 10. Um, but what
what are your thoughts on that?
Yeah, I mean the the point of the
parable is plain enough. It's simple in
itself. It it's simply talking about
those who accept Christ have a right uh
to enter in upon the joy of the Lord.
Those who don't don't. Right? the the
righteousness of Christ that closed us
is not something that becomes ours only
later, right, after some investigative
judgment. It takes place upon faith. So,
I do think that although you you know,
you're right, it's a larger topic and
could take us a while, but it's that's
really the essential problem with with
the interpretation here. Scripture
repeatedly speaks of believers upon
believing being justified before God.
And so if anybody shows up without that
righteousness, you know that they're he
kept smuggling in ideas that aren't
present in this text or elsewhere. It's
obviously derived from their system,
right? Where he's talking about all of
these are people uh that are in the book
of life, right? But uh they're all being
investigated and some are being exposed,
you know, as not worthy of Christ's
righteousness. None of that's present in
the verse. It's all being read in there.
The basic point of the parable is that
the gospel goes forth. Those who receive
it uh will be uh received on that day
and those who uh don't will be rejected.
Amen. I I agree. And it's always
fascinating to me too because if you
read Ellen White on this early on, this
was also used to support the shutd door
theory.
So, it was actually a two-fold deal
because again, the investigative
judgment came after the seven-year
period of them trying to figure out what
was going on with the disappointment. It
wasn't just like you're hearing now,
just immediately after 1844. It was a
progression where it's pivoted and
changed and things have moved around.
And uh it this was being used during the
seven-year period to try and justify the
door being shut um and that the door of
mercy was shut. But then obviously they
had to abandon that um and have arrived
at the conclusion that they're at now.
But I just think it's interesting that
at one point it had to include both this
investigation process and the door of
mercy being shut, but now it's only
referring to this investigation process
because the period of probation um was
essentially extended in 1844 is going to
be the claim. I got one more clip from
him here and then we'll be done with uh
done with clips, but I want to uh get to
this final thing that he says. This
one's pretty short.
Uh, hold up. I got to represent my
stream here.
He will bring the reward. So if Jesus
brings the reward, he must have
determined what the reward is before he
returns. That requires a judgment in
heaven. Notice what we find in Matthew
16 and verse 27 about when the reward is
given. It says there Jesus is speaking
for the son of man will come in the
glory of his father with his angels and
then he will reward each according to
his works. The works were examined in
the judgment in heaven before Jesus came
and the individual was shown to be
worthy to be rewarded with everlasting
life. Notice Revelation 22 and verse 12.
Here Jesus says, "And behold, I am
coming quickly and my reward is with me
to give to everyone according to his
work." Once again, works were examined.
When Jesus comes, the judgment is ended
and he is going to reward his people.
All right. So, two of their other
favorite passages, Matthew 16:27 and
Revelation 22:12.
Those verses prove this investigative
judgment, right, Anthony? Because as as
he said, Jesus is returning with rewards
for his people. That means there had to
be a judgment of his people in heaven to
determine what the reward is, right? And
see who's who's going to receive eternal
life.
Yeah. So, well, the first one is very
poorly chosen. Just picking that one. Uh
there's discussion about this text and
exactly what coming is in view there. I
think most people well most people
should whether they do or not should
recognize that coming language is used
throughout the Bible and it doesn't
always have reference to the same sort
of thing. So for example uh in the Old
Testament God came to Sinai that was
obviously a palpable visible thing. God
theophanically appeared. He he descended
upon Si and it was attended by great
signs and wonders. The mountain rumbled
and quake and so forth, right? But there
are other times when scripture speaks of
God coming where it doesn't refer to
something visible at all. I mean, look
at Isaiah 13 or Isaiah 19 where it talks
about God coming in judgment upon Egypt
or upon Babylon. In these cases, all
Bible interpreters recognize these were
events that were future for Isaiah, but
have since passed for us, right? So, the
prophets had all sorts of long-term
prophecies, but they also had these
short-term prophecies. And in Isaiah 13
and Isaiah 19, it's specifically things
that were more in the near or uh near
future. And in those cases, God did not
visibly appear. I don't know of anybody
that thinks so. Uh, and and the reason I
point this out is because in Matthew 16,
there's good reason to think this isn't
referring to Christ's future coming in
glory in the sense of uh, you that we
normally think of as the the second
advent or the the second coming of
Christ because you'll notice in
uh
the context it says verse 28, Truly I
say to you, there are some of those who
are standing here who will not taste
death until they see the son of man
coming in his kingdom. And so this means
I mean there's there's there's a way to
kind of determine or at least fix this
within a certain range because he says
that there are some who are standing
here who will not taste death until they
see the son of man coming in his
kingdom. This event has to be far enough
into the future that some have died,
right? even most but not so far in the
future that everyone present has died.
So some people would say that it's the
transfiguration of Christ mentioned in
the immediately following chapter that's
in view. That's the coming right where
Jesus reveals his glory. He's
transfigured before them which you might
then say is also a a foreshadowing of
when Jesus will finally climactically
come in glory. But still it it uh it
would mean that the immediate
fulfillment of what he's talking about
here had reference to the the
transfiguration. I don't think that's
what it is because I don't think that's
that far in the future that it makes
sense out of the words there are some of
those who are standing here who will not
taste death until they see the son of
man coming. I think this has to be
further enough in the future for many of
them who are present to have died. And
the event that most uh perfectly matches
this or answers to this would be the the
judgment on Jerusalem in AD70. And
before anybody gets excited, I'm
certainly not suggesting that everything
that in scripture was fulfilled in AD70.
I think that's a heresy. Christ is
definitely returning again. Uh he is
going to raise the dead and and judge
the world and consummate everything,
bring in a new heavens and a new earth.
But uh that doesn't mean that we have to
say every text talking about Christ
coming has reference to that final great
day. And here's one of these texts that
I just think you have to uh do a lot of
fanciful footwork. You have to be like
an exogetical cat on hot textual bricks
to try and make this refer to something
you know else. And uh
so so but but notice then notice the
problem because the same kind of
language is used in Revelation 22. So
even if I grant now notice that
Revelation 22 is about something yet
future
already we see this language being used
for something other than something like
an investigative judgment. Right? So
since we see the language can be used
this way for and it clearly doesn't mean
something like an investigative judgment
and and they don't even believe that the
Adventists. Well then uh for the same
reason I'd say you can't use Revelation
22 that way.
Yeah. Uh, I hear those two periodically.
Um, and it's typically always linked
with them mentioning Matthew 22 like
they did previously. And they'll
oftentimes not want to look at that
surrounding context and just quote those
verses to again look at it very
unid-dimensionally because there's
rewards that are going to be given and
that has to be determined. Well, that's
done in a judgment. Another one of their
favorite passages. And you'll notice
too, they love word association fallacy.
Like if the word judgment is there,
they're going to hitch 1844 to that and
bring all that
see meaning to inspect or something like
that. Correct.
Judgment.
Correct. So what about first Peter 4:17
though? Doesn't that say that judgment
begins at the house of God? And so
doesn't that show that there's going to
be an investigative judgment of God's
people?
Well, I mean, again, this is the same
problem I keep thinking about every time
you ask me something like like 1 John
1:9 or or these other passages. Do they
seriously think this is Peter talking
about 1844
or is Peter saying something relevant to
his contemporaries? He he speaks there
um as I recall uh of the people
experiencing a fiery ordeal. In fact, he
says the fiery ordeal that's among them,
right? And he tells them that it it it's
come upon them for their testing. Again,
he's talking to them. And so Peter says
they shouldn't consider it a strange
thing that this is happening to them,
right? Not people in 1844 or post 1844.
He's talking to people in the first
century. uh later in the context of of
fe first Peter 4 uh he says that they're
sharing in the sufferings of Christ.
That's what this is all about. They're
sharing in Christ's sufferings. Uh it's
a fiery trial. It's testing them. I mean
the whole point here is is similar to
what you see all throughout the Old
Testament. All throughout the Old
Testament,
the Lord talks about
uh the fact that you know his people he
chose them. He brought them to himself
and for that reason they have a special
responsibility before him. Right? I mean
think of the ten commandments. The the
prefaratory words of the of the ten
commandments are I am the lord your god
who brought you out of the house of or
out of Egypt or out of the house of
bondage. Right? Therefore go and have no
other gods before me. Uh the whole
reason they are told to obey is not so
that they might be redeemed, but because
they have been redeemed, but but notice
the order here. It's God has redeemed
them. Therefore, they're to live this
way. That puts them in a position of
special responsibility before the Lord.
And so in the prophets, when the when
the prophets upgrade the nation of
Israel, they often talk about how
they're going to be chastised, how
they're going to be uh punished. Uh, and
God even says he's going to use foreign
nations to do so, which you would expect
God to be wroth or, you know, uh, upset
with the foreign nations and so wipe
them out first, but he doesn't. He not
only doesn't do deal with them first, he
uses them to deal with his people,
right? So, he uses these foreign pagan
nations like Isaiah 10 uh, or Isaiah 36
and so forth. that talks about the
Assyrians being used by God as a rod of
correction for his people, right? Why?
Because as Amos says, "You only have I
known among all the families of the
earth. So, I'm going to deal with your
sins." Right? So, God deals with the
sins of his people. He often uses the
pagan nations to do it. And that's been
true all throughout history. Not once
the clock struck, you know,
I don't know, uh, 1 or whatever, uh,
1201 on 1844 or whatever the day was
that they say.
Yeah.
Uh, this Peter's just continuing an Old
Testament principle. God deals with his
people. He's testing them. He's refining
them. He's purifying them. The ongoing
work of sanctification,
you know, that's that's the whole goal.
The name of the game is conformity to
Christ. And that's always been what God
is up to in history with Israel and with
his people. He's purifying them. And uh
so again, it's just not a 1844 and and
after thing. It's a
for always and ever thing.
Yeah.
So this is one of those that I was
telling you that there's kind of a
undimensional. They see that, oh, I can
see I can support the idea that uh God's
people are judged, but then they're not
thinking through like, okay, well then
what? So, Peter was talking about 1844
that in 1844 a judgment's going to begin
specifically on the people of God
spanning all the way back to Adam and
it's going to be a test up against the
Ten Commandments to see who is and isn't
found worthy of the atoning benefits of
Christ's sacrifice. We didn't get into
that earlier. Um, but I think another
interesting thing that you pointed out
in the book of Hebrews that's really a a
a barn burner for this position is that
um, Christians currently partake of the
benefits of Christ. And the author tells
us that in Hebrews, but in this system,
there's an investigation taking place to
see who is going to receive the atoning
benefits of Christ sacrifice. They're
not something that you're necessarily
receiving currently. But now I want to
transition to and this is the last step
of this whole system and the one that I
think personally is um probably the most
blasphemous and that is the scapegoat
teaching. So I'm going to read something
to you here first. This is from
their book called Seventh Day Adventists
Believe. It is the exposition of their
own 28 fundamental beliefs book. And on
page 357 of the 2015 edition, it says,
"The scapegoat ritual on the day of
atonement pointed beyond Calvary to the
final end of the sin problem, the
banishment of sin and Satan. The now
they're going to quote one of their
scholars, the full accountability for
sin will be rolled back upon Satan, its
originator and instigator. Satan and his
followers and all the effects of sin
will be banished from the universe by
destruction.
Atonement by judgment will therefore
bring about a fully reconciled and
harmonious universe. Ephesians 1:10.
This is the objective that the second
and final phase of Christ's priestly
ministry in the heavenly sanctuary will
accomplish.
Anthony,
explain for the audience what was the
purpose of the scapegoat. Was it
something that dealt with who was
bearing responsibility
or did it have some other function?
Well, so, so first of all, I mean just
thinking about several things here, but
uh one is notice that in the Adventist
system, these are two events that are
separated by an incredible length of
time,
at least up to this point almost right
2,000 years.
That's not at all what you would gather
from
the alleged type, right? These two
things are are taking place
simultaneously. The uh sacrifice of the
one and the other being sent out into
the wilderness. Uh so I I don't see a
par there, right? These two things just
don't uh look alike. Uh you don't get
the impression that this is a type
antitype uh thing. And I can imagine any
Jew laughing at this. Yeah, it'd be
interesting thinking of an Adventist
trying to evangelize a Jewish person. Uh
they're already taught to think that we
artificially try and make things fit
Christ and and here uh they would have
to laugh I think all the more. Uh but uh
the other thing is they seem to not
realize that I mean how Old Testament
types and shadows work necessarily in
order to truly point to Jesus.
When you think about it in in the in the
case of Christ, obviously what he does
is as the reality there's there's going
to be something unique about it. the the
type can't answer to it uh exactly
because
I if it did then it wouldn't be the type
it'd be the reality right so one of the
things you have to think about is how
could God typify let's say
the the death of Christ for our sins and
his resurrection from the dead and his
ascension I mean all these different
things right through these Old Testament
figures who are not Jesus who therefore
aren't really making atonement for sin
or anything I
One of the things that would have to
happen is you'd you'd have to have
something of a composite image. Right?
So, let me give you an analogy of what
I'm thinking about here and then you can
ask me questions if if maybe I've I've
confused people, but uh hey, you've made
me listen to all these Adventist guys
who are as confusing as can be. But, uh
I don't think I'm confusing you just
yet, but you can tell me if I do. But
think think about Moses and Joshua is a
beautiful typology of the Lord Jesus.
But it takes two people to do it. So you
have in Moses the redemption from Egypt
taking place. Moses is the one who leads
them out of Egypt through the parted
waters of the Red Sea into the
wilderness. He there provides for them
and so forth. But they have not yet
entered into their final rest. Right?
They've they've been delivered out of
Egypt, but now they're traversing the
wilderness. They're they're sojouring in
the wilderness, which we can say
corresponds to our uh coming to faith in
Christ, but now we're sojouring in this
world. We're citizens of heaven. That's
where our citizenship is. But we haven't
yet entered into all of that uh in in
you know, the fullness of our
experience. It's just, you know, we
haven't done so yet. Um, but uh in order
for that to happen, Moses, the mediator,
has to die, right? Israel can't enter
into heaven or excuse me, I'm jumping
the gun here and already telling you
what I'm thinking the imagery typifies.
Israel can't enter into their promised
inheritance unless Moses, their
mediator, dies.
But then, who's going to lead them in?
Right. Right. If Moses is dead, there's
there's nobody then to uh you know do
this final step. And this is
accomplished in Joshua. In fact, Moses
is deliberately setting up Joshua as a
type of Jesus. Isn't he even changes his
name for no apparent reason? He changes
it from Hoshia, which means salvation,
to Yahosua, which means Jehovah saves or
Jehovah is salvation. And so he shows
that the one who's going to do this
consequent upon his death is is Joshua.
This is the one that God will raise up
in place of Moses. He's even portrayed
as a Moses-like figure. All sorts of
things are recapitulated in Joshua that
were already true in in Moses, right? He
he meets the captain of the Lord's host.
He tells him to take off his shoes for
he's standing on holy ground. All the
sorts of things that happened to Moses
at the burning bush. Uh the waters of
the Jordan are parted before Joshua,
right? over and over again, Joshua's
likened to Moses as his successor, the
one who who comes after him, which is a
type of the one who is ultimately going
to be the prophet like Moses. But what
I'm getting at then in this long-winded
way perhaps is that Moses and Joshua
together
as a composite picture are a type of
Jesus. And so the scapegoat when when
you have the one being offered and then
the other being sent out into the
wilderness, it it's not being presented
as, you know, one refers to Jesus and
the other refers to Satan. I mean, I I
know now why you're calling it
blasphemous. Uh notice in Leviticus 16
where it's talking about this. I I
imagine a lot of people miss this, but
verse 5, note carefully what it says. It
says, "He shall take from the
congregation of the sons of Israel two
male goats for a sin offering."
Notice it refers to both of these as the
offering. Right? So there this is the
point that I'm making that that both of
these are representing what Christ does
because in the nature of the case it's
got to present the picture of the
sacrifice
uh paying for sin but then also of our
sin then being taken away and how can
you do that with an animal when one of
them you know it's dead. it can't
signify in the presence of the people uh
this idea of the sin being born away.
And so two animals are needed for this
whereas they're both referring to one
offering namely to the one offering of
Christ which which does all of this
because Christ can right he can do all
of things and um yeah so I might have
forgot the question but I think I was
answering it.
No no you're good. You you did um and
and you hit the nail on the head there.
And I debated this with an Adventist
pastor. Um this is on my channel. Many
of you guys have have seen this. Um it's
titled heated debate between a 7th
Adventist pastor and a Christian. And it
was on this specific topic. And that was
the argument that I made. I said it was
two goats for one singular sin offering.
And the function of the scapegoat was
experation. The removal of the sin from
the people. it wasn't the uh sacrificed
goat. And because that's the case,
that's where they get this divide. So,
with what you just said in mind, let's
now look at their reasons for this. So,
here's the three reasons that they give
for why Satan better fits this figure.
Okay, this is also from that same book.
One, the scapegoat was not slain as a
sacrifice, so therefore can't possibly
be involved in bringing about
forgiveness. Only the shedding of blood
can do that. Hebrews 9:22.
Two, the sanctuary in Leviticus 16 was
entirely cleansed by the blood of the
Lord's goat before the scapegoat was
introduced into the ritual. Leviticus
16:20.
And the third reason, the passage treats
the scapegoat as a personal being who is
opposite of and opposed to God.
Leviticus 16:8 reads literally one to
Yahweh and the other to Aazil.
Therefore, in the setting of the
sanctuary parable, it's more consistent
to see the Lord's goat as a symbol of
Christ and the scapegoat Aazil as a
symbol of Satan.
Those are their three reasons for this.
What are your thoughts on that? Well, so
they they refuted themselves in the
third point. First of all, I don't even
know how they could write that and not
notice it. It in Hebrew it's aazel. It
has the lamemed preposition which means
to or for which in the nature of the
case means it's not if you're taking
aazel there. I should have mentioned
this as a reference to Satan. And
there's debate about that. I mean that
it's again it's it's amazing to me how
much of their theology is built on uh
extreme ambiguities or all sort you know
things that are easily debated by people
there. There's no clear dedactic
teaching of their c you know not just
doctrines that they hold but things that
are and in fact not even central
doctrines but ones that as you quoted
the guy earlier played the clip is
foundational to the system. Without it
the whole thing crumbles. So this is
just incredibly uh you know uh
precarious. But aazelle is not
necessarily a reference to Satan. I've
seen the arguments for it, but you know
it's again it's it's an ambiguous the
the septagen for example when it
translates it. This is a Jewish
translation prior to the time of Christ
doesn't take it as a reference to a uh
Satan or a demon or something like that.
That's not how it's understood. That
doesn't mean that there's no places you
could turn and point to, you know,
something that would maybe indicate uh a
demonic being or or Satan or something.
I'm just saying that it's it's by no
means settled. And but in any case, even
if it were, it's it says two or four.
And so
it's not a a symbol of Satan. I don't
even know how that would work into their
theology that this goat is sent to Satan
or for I mean,
how does that work?
Uh But yeah, so the other the other
reasons were the scapegoat is not slain.
Well, they they don't know their, you
know, their Jewish background. There was
somebody that would follow the goat and
I'm just telling you what Jews did. I
mean, they they followed it to make sure
that it would die, right? Either fall
off a cliff or something like that. That
was the expectation. This thing had to
die. But but besides that, it just
misses the point that what we just made
mention of that these two goats are are
filling out the whole picture. It's not
one goat, you know, that that does this
thing over here and then another goat to
I mean the full picture is of sin being
uh paid for through the death of the
sacrificial victim and it being
expedated. You need two goats to
illustrate that, but they're all
pointing to the one work of Christ. And
so,
uh, the idea that, well, the sanctuary
is cleansed and then the other one's
sent away just misses this connection
between these two goats as the one sin
offering.
Yeah. Yeah. And again, I pointed out in
that debate uh, that point exactly that
you have an error there if you're saying
that it's the goat is Aazil, but then
you're saying it's sent to Aazil and so
the goat typifies Satan, but it's sent
to Satan. Um, there's that
inconsistency, but it's very clear, one
singular sin offering. And we're not
saying that the the second goat was
slain the same way that the first goat
was, but there was blood involved. Cuz
they'll ask the question then, well, are
you saying then that there was a
bloodless
uh atonement being made? Well, no. Blood
was involved. They can't see the the
difference in function. And it's because
their system is built so heavily on this
that they try to prove too much. they're
trying to prove too much through type
antitype that it then causes these sorts
of breakdowns. Um,
so that is really the teaching, Anthony,
in a nutshell. Um, I think that that was
really beneficial. I'm glad we got to go
over kind of some of those key verses
that they use. There's obviously other
ones. Um, but we have some questions now
from the audience if you're ready to
take some of those. Okay.
Kevin's Kevin's Biblical Discussions
asks, "Is Anthony Rogers premill?"
No, he's not.
You want me to give a longer answer? I
don't mind.
Yeah, if you want to.
Yeah. I mean, I I don't usually get into
it too much. Uh not because it's not
important or that it's not relevant to
me. I I once had a guy, let me set it up
this way. I had a guy that asked me a
long time ago, he was going to start
doing some jail ministry. And so, uh, he
was, you know, had a little bit of
trepidation. You're going to, you know,
go in there with guys that are in there
for a reason. So, he he was looking for
some stuff to, you know, put steel in
his back. And he he said, you know, what
is it that gives you confidence? Because
he he knew I used I I mean, not only
used to, I still do, but uh used to do a
lot of evangelism. I'd engage all sorts
of groups. I've dealt with Muslims for
30 years, for example. And so, he's just
saying, you know, what do you what gives
you confidence? And I always mention
there's there's three things that that I
I go into any discussion with that uh
give me untold confidence. The first is
I believe that God is sovereign. And
that being the case, I know that nothing
can happen to me apart from his will.
That not a hair can fall from my head
unless he deems it good for his glory
and my, you know, eternal welfare and so
forth. So that's, you know, the first
thing. Uh secondly, I know the person
I'm talking to is surrounded and hounded
by God's revelation. the person I'm
talking to knows God and therefore I'm
I'm speaking to somebody who's already
got a witness. You know, it's like going
into a conversation
with a person and there's it's it's
always at least two against one, meaning
me and their conscience against them
because I know their conscience is on my
side, right? And of course, I know the
spirit is is at work in this. So it it's
the the conviction that everybody knows
God inescapably and is without any
excuse before him. Uh and then the third
thing is that I know Jesus is going to
win. Not merely uh at the end but in
history. I believe Jesus is presently
spreading his kingdom. He already is at
the right hand of the father. And
scripture says that he's at the right
hand of the father subduing all
creatures to himself. And and that's,
you know, some people will sometimes
look around and say that's not what it
looks like right now. You know, there's
a lot of people that don't believe in
him.
But scripture consistently presents that
as something that takes place
incrementally over time through the
activity of Christ in his church. So
that you have well, think of Daniel 2,
the passage that was mentioned earlier.
It mentions the rock being cut out
without hands. that smites the image on
the feet and then it grows until it it
fills the earth. You have the same
picture elsewhere where it talks about
uh a tree that's that's planted and then
it grows until it fills the whole earth.
Uh or uh the water that proceeds from
beneath the throne where it talks about
it getting larger and larger until you
know people are trying to swim in it. Uh
but uh lastly I just point out that uh
the incremental nature of this is seen
when it speaks for example in Isaiah 9
of the increase and peace of his
government there will be no end. Uh it's
the same thing in the the kingdom
parables in Matthew 13 where Jesus talks
about a little bit of leaven being put
into the the lump or or or a small you
know uh mustard seed being planted and
then becoming so large that it's the
largest in the garden right and and all
the birds of the air nesting in its
branches. So that's my conviction. I I
think that Christ uh is at the right
hand of the father and is subduing
everything beneath his feet and it's our
job to live that way and and and call
people to Christ.
Amen. We have the uh the same
esquetology.
Amen.
Question. In Revelation 21:22, John is
shown that there's no temple in heaven
and that the Lord is the temple. How do
SDAs interpret this text? Can we link
Jesus raising the temple in three days
to Revelation 21:22? Great question. Um,
I've brought this up before to them. Um,
the only response that I've gotten, not
that there aren't others out there, the
only response that I've gotten is, well,
right, that's in the new creation. The
current temple will be it'll be done
away with and obliterated. There won't
be one there in that new creation, but
right now we're we're not in the new
they the heaven that exists now is not
the new heaven. So, this is referring to
the new heaven, which won't have one,
but the current heaven does.
So, that's the response that I've heard
from them. Um, but as it pertains to
that second part, um, Anthony, I'll let
you chime in, um, and see if you have
any thoughts. How do, uh, should we link
Jesus raising the temple in three days
to Revelation 21:22?
Okay. So,
the Old Testament
talks about
the Messiah building the temple of the
Lord. Uh, there's all sorts of passages
that that talk about that. When you get
to the New Testament, it's quite evident
that it's talking about well, in the
first place, he is the temple or the
cornerstone. Uh, and we are living
stones that are being built together as
a holy temple in the Lord. Uh, so the
the the final goal of of creation is
that we are the temple in which the Lord
dwells or among whom he dwells. That's
the goal of the covenant. It's the goal
of all God's covenantal dealings. When
you look at the the the the constant
refrain or words spoken in connection
with the covenant is sometimes it's
giving in in a more uh truncated way but
the full expanded form of it is uh I
will be their god they will be my people
and I will dwell in their midst right or
I will walk among them right sometimes
you just have I will be their god or
they will be my people or I will walk
among them or I will dwell among them
but the full phrase is is as I gave it
and And and that's the idea. That's what
that that's the way things were in the
beginning, right? When when God created
Adam and Eve and then uh established his
dwelling among them in paradise. And so
that's what was lost and that's what
everything is is heading towards now.
And so that's what Revelation 22 speaks
of is realized.
Yeah. Um, I think one other thing I'll
mention too, just for what it's worth,
um, they'll sometimes, so when you
listen to some of these bigname
Adventist preachers that teach on this
investigative judgment, they will try
and weasle this aspect in as well and
say, "Well, this cleansing of the
sanctuary is multifaceted because we are
the sanctuary. We're the body of
Christ." And so, it's a cleansing act
that's taking place of God's people as
well. Um, so it's not just a building in
heaven. So, some of them will shy away
from, well, how did heaven become
defiled? Well, it's actually in
reference to the temple of our of our
bodies and that we're the we're the body
of Christ that make up the temple and
it's a cleansing work that God's doing
of his people. Um, so it's going to be
all that to say it's going to probably
be across the spectrum in terms of um
the specific SDA response to this. I'm
waiting to get the new SDA Bible
commentary that comes out um so that I
can give people more pointed answers on
what their specific teaching is on any
given text.
Kevin has another question. What do you
think the everlasting gospel is that is
proclaimed by the angels in Revelation
14?
Oh, so that's for me, huh?
Or Yeah, for Well, I it could be for
both of us. I'm assuming or I'm going to
guess our our answer is going to be the
same, but I'll let you go.
Yeah. There there's only one gospel and
so it better be that one.
Yeah.
And it is.
It's Yeah. It's And sometimes people
will ask the question of, "Well, the
gospel wasn't given until the new
covenant." And um that's not true. Paul
says that God preached the uh gospel to
Abraham before um that during the the
patri the period of the patriarchs um
for seeing the engrafting of the
Gentiles. He preached the gospel to
Abraham. And so yes, there's only and I
have a channel or a video on the
homepage of the channel on this. there's
only one gospel. Um God and that gospel
was revealed by Jesus Christ to the
apostles. The apostles then handed that
down to what we have today. Um Paul
clearly says in Galatians 1, there's
only one gospel. Any other gospel is not
actually a gospel. But anyone that
proitizes those false gospels are
actually cursed by God. Jesus did not
then reveal to John the Apostle a
different gospel that's cursed from what
he revealed to the apostles. Um, so it
is the once-forall gospel that was
handed down by Jesus Christ to the
apostles and through the ages.
Yeah. One one other passage to throw in
is Hebrews 4 where it says that the good
news or the gospel was preached to us
just as it was to them.
Yeah.
But they didn't mix the hearing.
The wilderness wanders. Yeah.
Yeah.
Question for both of us here. Fred wants
to know what we think the mark of the
beast is.
you you got me on your channel just so
that the world would would know the
position of Anthony Rogers on
esquetology.
Uh I I say that again because the you
know normally I don't mention
esquetology a whole lot because there's
a lot of stuff that I want people to
learn that I know some people will
immediately turn you off because you're
not, you know, uh speaking to what their
pet esquetology is. People prioritize
esquetology in a way that I don't think
they should. I mean, I don't think you
should minimize the importance of
anything in God's word. We're not at
liberty to disbelieve what God has said.
We have to believe what he reveals. But
there are some things that are
comparatively less important and more
difficult to work through than than
others. And I just don't think a lot of
people tend to know where these things
fit in. And so, for example, I mean, I I
remember I I was at I used to work at a
bookstore and and there was a guy that
wanted to persuade me of his particular
view of tongues. And every day I went
into work, it was uh mortifying. He
wanted to talk about tongues. And I was
like, "This guy's killing me." And so,
one day I said to him, I said, "Hey," I
said, "Suppose I was hit by a car on the
side of the road and I was gasping for
air and about to die." I said, "If you
were going to give me the gospel in a in
a few minutes, uh, what would you tell
me?" me and he goes, "Well, well, um uh"
and so as he's humming and hawing, I
said, "You know, I'll give him a jump
start." And I said, "Well," I said, "For
example," I said, "You tell me that
Christ, the eternal son of the father,
came down from heaven. You became
flesh." And he says, "Wait, what?" He
says, "Christ eternal." And I said,
"What do you mean, wait, what? You know,
Christ eternal?" And he basically he's
saying to me that he didn't track with
me when I was talking about Christ being
the eternal son.
So, he didn't even know who Jesus was.
That's the upshot of this. He didn't
know who Jesus was, but he sure knew
what he thought about tongues. And he
sure knew what he thought about other
Christians who didn't share his view of
tongues. And I'm thinking, well, I know
in scripture Jesus said, "Unless you
believe that I am, you'll die in your
sins." Using the divine selfveration
formula from John 8, meaning you have to
confess his deity to be saved. Uh, but
you know, there's nothing corresponding
to that with respect to tongues. And so
basic point here is I I get a lot of
people that you know if I don't tow the
line on their esquetology they're
they're going to turn off what I have to
say to them about solid solos scriptor
solos christrista solaria all these
other doctrines that I think are
necessarily
uh known by them you know things they
must know but anyways that's my long
intro to say hey
uh
listen but uh don't discount everything
else I Hey, if if you don't agree with
me, but uh I if you look at the book of
Revelation, again, I've already said
that I don't
I don't agree with hyper predtoism,
which I think is better called
pantelism, which is the heresy that
everything has happened. Jesus already
returned in every sense. Uh the
resurrection has already occurred. The
new heavens and new earth are already a
reality, right? All that's a charade.
It's it's it's an illusion. It's it's
not biblical uh and it's contrary
historical. The church has never
believed that. At the same time, I think
there is much in scripture that has been
fulfilled and there's a significant
reason that we were given stuff relating
to that because it it plays a vital role
in the outworking of redemption. So, as
as an example, what I mean is I mean the
old covenant system was a system of
types and shadows that was intended to
point to Jesus. Paul says that it was a
pedagogue, right? It was a tutor to lead
us to Christ. And that means that it had
an appointed end. It was pointing, you
know, if I have a picture of my family
because they're gone, I'm looking at it
and so forth, and then my family comes
home and I sit there staring at the
picture instead of kissing my wife and
hugging my kids or whatever, right? That
that somebody's going to be upset,
right?
uh the the picture serves in the absence
of the reality.
Well, the the Jews were clinging to the
shadows because they thought those were
an end in themselves. They didn't see
that as a tutor pointing to Christ. And
so, the whole point of the book of
Hebrews is that Christ has rendered all
of that obsolete. Right? All of that uh
was pointing to Jesus and now by virtue
of his coming has been rendered
obsolete. And in Hebrews 8:13, the
author of Hebrews says, "What has been
rendered obsolete is about to disappear,
right? So all of that is about to go the
way of all the earth." The author of
Hebrews says, "That's why it's so
foolish for you guys to go hankering
back to these things just because you
haven't seen it happen yet." You know,
you're thinking, "Well, where is all
this? You know, why hasn't it happened
yet?" Paul, uh, the author of Hebrews,
whether it's Paul or somebody else, is
saying it is obsolete because Christ has
come and it's going to be done away
with. Okay, so why am I saying all this?
Well, because I I do think that many
things stated in the New Testament have
reference to that climactic
uh covenant ending event that signified
the old, you know, all that stuff has
has been completed. Uh Jerusalem's
destruction is a hugely significant
event in the history of redemption. It
was the the great, you know, uh, you
know, public indication that God's
purposes as illustrated in in these
ceremonial ordinances and so forth had
had come to completion. And so when you
look at the book of Revelation,
again, watch I I think people jump
through hoops here when they don't need
to, but the book of Revelation begins
and ends on a clear note of the nearness
of these things, right? It uses three
different words as if you know people
are going to have trouble seeing the
point with one. Uses three different
words to indicate how close these things
are. You know it uses soon, quickly and
uh uh you know about to happen, right?
And it uses these words over and over
again. It uses them at critical
junctures at the beginning and end of
the book even at various junctures in in
along the way like the the souls
underneath the altar say uh you know how
long oh lord until you know you avenge
us and then the lord says you know just
a little while right so again you've got
this language over and over again the
reason I'm pointing this out is because
it's in this context that the discussion
is given about the beast and the beast I
I'll try and be quicker here there's
there's a lot more that needs to be said
the beast. It mentions
uh right seven heads uh on this uh this
character and then it tells us that
these seven heads have a two-fold
reference, right? On the one hand, those
seven heads represent seven hills on
which the woman sits. Everybody knew in
the ancient world what the seven hills
would have been a reference to. Rome was
a uh was founded on seven hills, right?
It was a seven hill settlement. You even
had on their coins the goddess Roma, a
woman sitting on seven hills. Uh but
John says it's a two has twofold
reference, right? The seven hills on
which the woman sits. He also says the
seven heads represent seven kings. He
says five have fallen. One is the other
has not yet come. If you count the kings
starting or the emperors of Rome
starting with Julius Caesar, the sixth
king is Nero which is the one that John
is saying was alive while he's writing.
He's telling he's even telling you when
the book was written right during the
reign of that sixth king. Uh so happens
that Nero's name Neuron Kaiser in Hebrew
is 660.
That's the numerical equivalent of it.
Interestingly enough, there's a variant
in the manuscript tradition of the
number of the beast, which is 616.
And Nero's name in Latin is numerically
equivalent to 616. So, it's almost as if
they're covering both bases, so you
don't miss who this figure is. Uh, and
and I can go on and on with that. So,
the basic point that I'm making is I
think it's talking about uh Rome. It's
talking about the coming destruction of
Jerusalem. uh and Nero is the specific
figure that that's in view when it talks
about a mark and so forth. Uh doesn't
mean I think that uh again Christ is
coming again. He certainly is. I think
that the end of the book does get into
that right a you know it talks about
Christ coming after uh Satan is released
again and then another conflration
happening at the end of all that. That's
my long answer.
Yeah. Well, and it's I think people need
to understand too cuz when you deal with
Adventists, they think they've cracked
every sign, symbol, number. Um, it's
it's just all super simple. This is like
you were mentioning earlier, they only
want to talk about esquetology. It's
like it's everything. It's foundational
to the whole system. And the reality is
is that this is a very advanced area of
theology and it does it takes a lot of
getting into and a lot of explaining
there. So, I'm glad you gave a good
backstory there. Um, and thankfully I
hold to the same position that you do.
though I will literally just mirror what
you said. I didn't always hold to that
position. Um but um just the the
immediate application to the original
audience it was written to, you know. Um
you have to deal with that. This the
coming soon had to have an application
to the original audience it was written
to.
Yeah. And by the way, I mean this was a
huge apologetic point for early
Christians. They constantly pointed to
the finality
that was evident, right? It was right
there. You could point to Jerusalem and
say, "Look, Jesus fulfilled all that.
Where is it?" Right? The the Jews had to
deal with that. It was a thorn in their
side. That's why Julian the Apostate,
who was an emperor after Rome, became a
Christian nation. Julian the Apostate,
he he was a an emperor after Constantine
and so forth, he reverted back to
paganism and he wanted to do away with
this argument on the part of Christians.
So he tried to aid the Jews in going
back to Israel to rebuild Jerusalem and
rebuild the temple and so forth. And
this is according to historical record.
So people can make of this whatever they
want, but this is what the records say
that the Jews went over there and
attempted to reconstruct the building,
but subterranean vaults uh ignited so
that there was like fire and combustion
that came up from beneath the ground and
consumed them. Uh interesting, you know,
detail that again it comes to us in
historical sources. Uh so my my point
though is just to say you mentioned the
historical the contemporary relevance of
this to the Christians. John is writing
to seven historical churches in Asia
Minor for whom these things were very
important, very significant and and he
was saying these all these all they're
supposed to read this, understand it,
take it to heart and and and heed the
words that are written for a reason,
right? Which wouldn't make sense if it
wasn't on the near horizon. But also is
the fact that for the early Christians,
this gave great apologetic impetus to
their message that God had definitively
wiped all of this out. Uh it's a signal
display of the fact that Christ
fulfilled these things.
Amen.
21st century Paul asks, "So Satan was
allowed in the sanctuary court." Uh
Paul, I'll do you one better. Um he was
allowed in the holy place. In this
vision that Ellen got um of Jesus
getting up off the throne with the
father in the holy place and moving to
the most holy place. Um there were two
groups of people there. The little
flock, which is what the SDAs became,
claimed that when Jesus got up, their
eyes tracked with him and they followed
him into the most holy place. But when
doing so, she looked back at the
careless multitude, all the other
Christians who rejected this message
that they were supposedly heralding,
this midnight cry. And in doing so, she
saw that Satan crept into the holy place
and stood next to the throne. And when
these people would send up their
prayers, they were sending them to the
holy place, but Jesus wasn't there
anymore. So, he wasn't even hearing
their prayers. She says that Satan was
allowed to breathe on them an
influencing spirit in response to their
prayers that they thought that they were
sending up to God and bring essentially
a delusion on these people. And that was
a judgment from God on them rejecting
this 1844
um you know at that time actually shut
door which then birthed this
investigative judgment teaching. So all
that to say that um yes that was in
vision. She didn't claim to physically
be there in heaven and physically see
Satan in there. But my point still
stands that um you're referring to the
scapegoat doctrine of um Satan being the
scapegoat and the scapegoat was brought
into the court. Um so yes, not just the
court but also the uh the holy place.
I have to say hearing a lot of this
stuff uh the the deity of the Seventh
Day Adventist sounds very finite. Uh, I
mean just all the talk about
investigation and uh, you know, Satan
surreptitiously doing things, you know,
sneaking in and um, all
his hands are tied. Um because if you
remember at the end of my steelman of
the investigative judgment um God the
whole point of this is not for God to
learn information they'll say but for
him to uh vindicate his character
because this whole thing and this whole
process goes back to this great
controversy narrative that in say in
heaven Lucifer became jealous of the
exaltation of Jesus to be made equal
with the father. He started to think
things like, "Why wasn't I exalted? I'm
beautiful." And all these other things.
He then began rebelling by saying that
God's law is not fair because the Ten
Commandments govern heaven in their
system. They're eternal in that sense.
They're the foundation of God's throne.
They say the mercy seat is God's throne
and the Ten Commandments are underneath
that. Well, there's a there's an arc
like that in heaven as well because
again, it was a copy of what's in
heaven. And so, Satan began accusing
against that. And in this great
controversy, um, God has to vindicate
his character against these accusations.
They'll say the reason God didn't just
blot Satan from existence immediately
upon his rebellion is because if he
would have done that, it would have
shown that Satan's accusations were
true, that God's a tyrant. So, he has to
figure out a way to silence the
accusations of Satan and silence that
and show all the watching intelligences
that he is who he says he is. So, it's a
big thing for us to like Stephen Bore,
that guy we looked at earlier, in one of
his presentations on this, which we
reviewed this in a different video um
from last week uh or the week before,
and he says in that presentation that so
in the millennial reign, they believe
it's basically going to be a giant
fact-checking session of what God did in
the investigative judgment. And that in
that millennial reign, they'll be able
to see, okay, who we can trust him.
Think about that. You're going to be
with Almighty God. And it's at that
point you'll be able to say after you
you say like, "Why isn't grandma here?"
He'll be able to show you the books and
the record of her life and that God was
just in not bringing grandma to heaven.
So then they can go, "Oh, okay. I can be
put at ease." So all of that to say,
yes, their god is very uh
anthropomorphic. He's ve in like his
being. He's uh he's bound by time. They
say that timelessness is like an
arisatilian idea. Um that God is
actually bound in time that time will
continue in heaven. Um they don't
believe that the the the triune God like
we do. They believe in three different
corporeal tangible literal forms and
those three are one in their mission and
their purpose. So they're essentially
one God. Um but these three different
individuals function like a team they
say. Um so it's a mess.
The two witnesses talking about
revelation again, symbolism or actual
people.
Oh, you're going to kick it to me again,
huh?
So, I would just take it as a reference
to two people. There would be disputes
over this, but
couple of things here. I mean, number
one,
Revelation 11 talks about the two
witnesses.
it
the context. This is John writing in the
first century and this is all taking
place in the shadow of the temple,
right? The the passage begins with the
temple being measured as though it's
something still standing. There's no
indic it's not talking about a rebuilt
temple or that that whole notion is not
even found in the New Testament.
Revelation 11 talks about a the temple
being measured and it talks about these
two witnesses bearing witness and it
specifically says that they're
prophesying in Jerusalem right because
it later it talks about their their
bodies lying dead in the streets of the
gate great city which it says
spiritually
is called Sodom and Egypt and then it
goes on to give the interpretation where
their Lord was crucified. Nobody
questions where that was. That was
Jerusalem. Elsewhere in scripture,
Jerusalem is called uh by the names like
Sodom or Egypt and what have you. So uh
that's not surprising when John does it.
So this is taking place in Israel. It's
taking place in Jerusalem. The temple
still standing and these two witnesses
are
uh prophesying and we have copious
evidence of early Christian prophetic
activity in the first century.
especially
towards the time when Jerusalem was
destroyed. So much so, one of my
favorite accounts and you know, it's
it's funny when I I sometimes when I
hear people bing at this idea that this
is what you know was referring to the
first century, the destruction of
Jerusalem and so forth, the the ending
of the old covenant system and all that.
Um you get people saying how is this
fulfilled? How you know like it's just
impossible, right?
and then but it betrays an unfamiliarity
with what happened in that event. It's
amazing the precision with which these
things happened. So here's here's just
one of the things I was saying is my one
of my favorites in when the Romans
surrounded Jerusalem. Okay, first of
all, you know, you you have this this
problem, right? The the Romans have
surrounded Jerusalem. How are the early
Christians now going to escape? Jesus
had told them when you see Jerusalem
surrounded by armies you know then he
says flee right uh flee because there
you know you're not going to win this
right this is not intended for Israel to
win but how do you flee it's surrounded
well what happened when Titus went in is
he initially or when uh when the Roman
forces went in they initially surrounded
it but because the emperor had died they
uh they had to go back to Rome and and
so there was a temporary withdrawal from
the city and that allowed the Christians
to escape this is all recorded in
Christian sources, Ucius, for example,
in his church history records this, they
they fled to uh Petra and so they
escaped the confflgration. Uh but then
the Romans came back, they encompassed
Jerusalem. But here's the specific thing
that's interesting is so they had these
these catapults that were like
scorpions, by the way. They packed quite
a wall up in their tails. Uh and they
even bore this name. But uh these these
catapults had 100 pound stones in them,
right? Remember John talks about uh 100
pound hailstones pummeling this
adulterous woman, right? Who's got
blasphemous names on her forehead,
right? Um well anyways the this these
catapults when they would shoot these
stones the the stones were originally
white and uh so white that they would
let off this glare from the sun and so
they would go through the sky and and
Josephus is describing this as having
almost like this bl if you looked right
at it would it would kind of be blinding
because it would reflect the sun and it
also let off this hideous hurling
whirling noise, Right?
And he said that the watchman on the
walls, now catch this. This is Josephus.
He's not a Christian. He he was a Jew.
He was from Galilee. In fact, he was the
leader of the the forces before he was
beaten by the Romans who then was, you
know, taken by them when they went off
after Jerusalem. Well, Josephus is
recording that the the watchmen on the
walls as this first stone comes hurling
at them, letting off the the
respplendance of the sun and and making
this this whirling noise, the watchmen
on the walls were crying out, "The sun
is coming. The sun is coming." It's not
su n. It's s o n in Josephus. M
the watchmen on the walls took this as
the indication that the sun was coming
because as Josephus also tells us there
were people that were preaching that the
destruction that Jerusalem was going to
be destroyed. He's referring of course
to the first century Christians. First
century Christians would have been
telling I mean imagine it. I mean Amos
says that God doesn't do anything
without first revealing it through his
servants the prophets. I mean certainly
nothing of such redemptive significance
as that would have been unannounced. And
so we know again from historical
sources, Christian and Roman, that the
early Christians were prophesying the
coming judgment of Jerusalem. And uh in
that context, there's no problem for
trying to find, you know, uh locate two
witnesses. I'm not saying I know who
they were. I'm just saying that, you
know, Josephus gives us ample evidence
that there were Christians. pro not just
he's not just talking about what we have
in the New Testament like the ET
discourse or something like that. He's
talking about actual prophets who are
prophesying the coming judgment.
That nice kid04 says keyword vision. I
think he's speaking back or he or she is
speaking back on uh what I was saying
earlier about the the holy place vision.
Peter had a vision about eating unclean
animals in Acts 10 that had nothing to
do with food. Visions have symbolic
meanings. Um I'm aware uh madam or sir.
Um which is why I said at the end it's a
vision. I know it was a vision. Um I
didn't say that she was she was
physically there. In responding to the
anyard,
um I was simply saying that um even in
vision you have Satan coming into the
holy place and prayers going up to him
um and him being able to breathe an un
uh holy spirit, I think is the language
that she uses in that specific quote.
Another comment, same person. I wish one
day you would have an Adventist
apologist on your show so that it isn't
you just saying what they believe. Well,
sir, get them to come on the channel.
How about you come on the channel? You
guys like to shoot spitballs in the
comments and say that I'm not willing to
engage with Adventists. Sir, if you can
get them to show up, I'll gladly have
them on here. Have them email me
answering adventism@gmail.com.
They won't do it. If you don't think I
know what I'm talking about, you step up
to the plate and silence me. Let's see.
Remember in grade school how you had to
show your homework when you turned in
your your projects? Come step up to the
plate and let's see who's ready to show
their homework. I'm willing to stand
behind the homework that I've done. Are
you? Are you? You guys like to paint the
picture that I don't know what I'm
talking about and I'm just constantly
talking about what SDAs believe. I'm not
just some outside figure. I've read
thousands of pages of Mrs. White. My
dad's a pastor. I was raised in the
church. I was a I'm a former Seventh Day
Adventist, third generation, educated
all the way up through other than high
school SDA institutions.
If I don't know what I'm talking about
and it's just me shooting out the side
of my neck and claiming things that they
don't actually believe, you come on to
the show and you silence me.
Ken Brooks. Ken must have missed Ken
must have missed uh the uh earlier
discussion around Colossians 2. Why does
Sunday worshippers discard the fourth
commandment saying that God's holy law
was nailed to the cross? Can neither of
us believe that God's law was nailed to
the cross. So, um I wouldn't saddle all
people who, um I wouldn't also call us
Sunday worshippers, um but going to
church on the the Lord's day. Um we
don't believe the law was nailed to the
cross. So, that doesn't apply to us.
Anything you'd like to add to that,
Anthony?
I'll make a comment on the fourth
commandment if you think it's in order.
Go for it.
Yeah. So,
I I'm going to mention something that I
think is important that is often not
mentioned. So there's a lot of other
stuff of course that's relevant to this,
but I like to mention it when I get an
opportunity because I think it it should
have weight with people. It should be
part of what they consider. But one of
the things that Adventists missed and
and this is something that I mentioned
before. I don't have a lot of experience
with Adventists, but what experience I
had often revolved around discussions on
the fourth commandment. So I know
something of of how they reason. Plus
there's other groups out there who
advocate the seventh day, right?
Observing the seventh day still. But so
there's often a lot of emphasis placed
on the fact that uh the seventh day is
connected to creation. This is this sign
of you know indicates that we we believe
that God is the creator and owner of
everything, right? That sort of thing.
Uh one of the things that people don't
seem to get uh is
biblical theology. You know, some of
what we're talking about is exogetical
stuff. We're dealing with some
systematic theological topics. But
biblical theology which is uh a
discipline where it talks you look at
the flow of redemptive history and what
God is doing and how God is uh moving
things and establishing along the way
patterns, words, motifs and so forth in
order that in terms of them he might
then uh reveal certain things down the
road. Well, the if you look at the
fourth commandment as stated in Exodus
20 and Deuteronomy 5, it's interesting
that there's a a reason that's a next to
the fourth commandment. In fact, there's
a different reason given in both cases.
They both are true. It's just the point
is that the the commandments as given in
both places arely different in their
wording. Uh one gives one reason, one
gives another reason. So in in Exodus 20
the reason given for observing the
fourth commandment is because of
creation. In six days the Lord made
heaven and earth and on the seventh he
rested. In Deuteronomy 5 the reason
annexed to the fourth commandment is
because of redemption. God redeemed them
from Egyptian bondage. Right? So they're
to cease from their labors and they're
not to make their servants labor either.
So notice this. the the fourth
commandment has as its stated reasons
creation and redemption. Well, if you
follow what's happening in scripture,
it's quite evident that the original
creation has fallen and needs to be
renewed. It needs to be recreated. There
needs to be not only a new creation, but
a a redemption, right? A and not just
the the typical redemption from Egypt.
That there needs to be the true
redemption, right? the the one that that
redemption was actually pointing to. And
when you come to the prophets, they
began to unpack this whole idea that
Moses was already telling you about all
along the way, but you you probably
missed I I'm I'm not saying that about
some specific person, but a lot of
people missed that Moses is doing this
over and over again, right? Where he's
indicating the need for a new creation,
a new redemption, right? That's what the
the whole point of circumcision is to
show the need for a new heart, right?
You need to be a new creature. That's
why Moses in Deuteronomy 30 says, "You
can't serve the Lord. You guys have hard
hearts, right? You you have
uncircumcised hearts. But God is going
to give you a new heart in the future."
And that's what the prophets pick up on.
If you look at Jeremiah, you look at
Ezekiel, you look at Isaiah, in one way
or another, they they unpack this idea
that God is going to bring about a bre a
better redemption and a new creation.
Okay? Based on that that redemption.
Why is that significant? Well, remember
the fourth commandment was based on this
these facts, the the original creation
and the redemption from Egypt. But if
all that is pointing forward to a new
redemption and a new uh creation, well
then
by virtue of that, it it uh brings with
it a a a new day that that corresponds
to it. And so when we come to the New
Testament and we see that Christ
provided atonement and then rose from
the dead and entered into uh his rest,
all of that is clearly uh related to
Sunday, not Friday or Saturday and so
forth. Jesus sat down at the right hand
of his I mean everything I mean think
about this. I don't know if you've
noticed this, but scripture mentions
Jesus
rising again from the dead, right? And
then it it mentions him ascending into
heaven and then it mentions Pentecost,
right? But there's all these uh
post-resurrection appearances in between
Christ's resurrection on that first day
and his eventual ascension, right? The
the the Pentecost takes place of course
on Sunday, right? Um, but not only the
first resurrection day, not only all of
those appearances were on a Sunday, but
every single subsequent appearance of
Christ that we're told about when when
we're told what day it was, it was
always on a Sunday, right? So, every
single day that Jesus appeared to his
gathered disciples was on a Sunday as
was uh Pentecost and so forth. And all
of this is why the early Christians w
without you know any dispute began
gathering on that day, right? The
distinctive first day gatherings were
always on Sunday. I mean I know that the
apostles went around into the synagogues
on Saturday and and witnessed to Jews
and so forth, but the distinctively
Christian gatherings were always on the
first day of the week. Acts 20, 1
Corinthians 16, Revelation 1:10. That's
why from the the get there's no debate
over that. That's why the early church
from the beginning long before Rome was
even a factor to impose anything on
anyone, Christians were worshiping on
the first day of the week, right? For
what it's worth.
Well, and you hit on the the key thing
and the reason that Adventists really
struggle with this is twofold. Um you
mentioned biblical theology. Um this is
an area where they'll often hold an
inconsistent standard and say, "Show me
a single verse that says the Sabbath was
changed to Sunday." Well, show me a
single verse that says Jesus is God. um
you guys claim to believe that. Um so
the the verbatim argument is an
inconsistent standard to hold. But
second off, if you can't see that the
new creation's been inaugurated, 2
Corinthians 5, um you're really going to
be able to or you're really going to
struggle on why the Christian church
understands what the Christian church
does in this area. So the key to the the
answer there is not hating or
disregarding God's holy law. Um, but it
has to do with disagreeing with the
faulty Adventist interpretation and
application and uh unlawful wielding of
that law, if you will. So, all right
folks, we're going to wrap it up. It's
been about three hours. Anthony, thank
you so much for being here. Let people
know really quick where they can find
your channel at. He is tagged in the
description box down below. So, you can
just click that link and it'll take you
to his channel. Um, but any parting
thoughts that you'd like to share with
anyone?
Yeah. So, I have the very uh noncreative
YouTube
channel uh Anthony Rogers. I mean, the
titles on creative. Hopefully, the
content is uh robust, but uh yeah, you
can you can find me over there. I've got
videos dealing with all sorts of topics.
I do all sorts of evangelistic and
apologetic related stuff as well as
biblical theological, systematic
theological stuff.
uh
you name it, I tend to try and get into
some of it over there. Uh so that's
where you can find me if you're
interested.
Cool. Well, like I said, thank you so
much for being here. Maybe we'll do
something like this again in the future
uh on a different topic, but uh I think
that this will be uh really beneficial.
So, thank you. Thank you all for being
here as always. Um I will see you guys
around next time. God bless.
[Music]